Can we go four,
three,
two
on boom,
and now we're live.
How are you sir?
I am wonderful.
We had wonderful chat.
Ofsted.
Yeah,
you probably would love to have had that
on here,
but I just.
No,
no,
no.
I would never want to do that to you.
Yeah,
no idea.
Exactly.
I wouldn't want to do that too.
Yeah.
So listen man,
it's great to see you again.
It's good to see you again.
Been a while.
Yeah,
we,
I know.
We ran into each other once in a bar,
men with a random eye candy and I tell
her that what it's called.
I turned around and you turn around and
we made eye contact and eye candy.
That was a long time and still have to
be about 25 years ago.
Four years ago now,
right?
I know we talked about doing a podcast
back then even.
Yeah.
I'm glad we finally got together and do
it.
Let me too.
It's going to be fun.
You did that TV show that I did a long
time ago.
Joe Rogan questions everything and you
blew me away.
You and me and Duncan and you showed us
all the tricks that people use.
Well you didn't.
You showed us that they were tricks,
but you didn't show us how to do the
tricks.
Broke one thing down for you,
but that was about it.
It was a psychological thing because
here's the thing,
right?
It's,
it's better to know that you can be
fooled rather than tell you how you can
be fooled and we'll.
We'll get into this about with
scientists and how I fold them in a
little bit,
but people always tell me,
why don't you just teach Paris the
tricks and the problem is,
is for every single trick that I have,
I probably have about seven or eight
methods,
so if I teach you one method,
Joe,
somebody else will come along and maybe
a method had been to key.
They'll do it a completely different
convincing way and you'll be looking for
that one method and you may say because
you don't have the experience,
you may say,
oh,
this has to be real.
I know how the tricks done.
They're not doing that.
They are actually doing something
completely different.
This has to be real,
so it's better to get an expert.
Let me ask you this one because my
friend Eddie was at Venice beach and
this guy was doing.
He has like some save the rain forest
thing and he said,
if I tell you your birthday will,
will you listen to me and and donate
some money or something like that.
Right.
And he goes,
okay,
and he just goes May 15th.
Right.
Just straight out like that.
Yeah.
I just figured it out.
I'm like,
how could someone do that?
I can't tell you because I wasn't there.
There could've been other circumstances.
They could have been something you
overheard.
They could have been something he seen.
He may have been in the store when the
guy took his driver's license that they
could be.
There's a million things that could have
happened that your friend Eddie was not
aware of before that guy even walked up
to him.
So I can't.
I really can't answer that because it's
circumstantial.
And here's the other thing.
Does Eddie really remember everything
exactly the way that it was,
you know,
has he forgotten something and left
something out in that story because he's
told it so many times.
And usually here's the thing,
right?
When people want to convince you of
something,
they embellish and the more times they
tell that story,
that embellishment their reality,
they basically create a whole new
reality for themselves that they forget
that maybe they wrote it down,
they forget that maybe they said
something,
they forget that the person might have
asked specific questions.
You might've said,
yeah,
I get the feeling that you're probably
not born in the beginning of the year,
maybe later in the year,
maybe in the fall or something like
that.
Person says,
no,
but I am bought land.
Even the edit now,
you know,
it's the winter time,
so now you get within a few months right
there.
So there's,
there are always within mentalism,
which is what I am,
a mentalist and we'll explain what that
is in a minute.
But um,
there are ways to do those things and
there's many ways to do those types of
things.
So without being there,
I can't tell you exactly what your
friend Eddie experience to him,
it was very,
very real.
You don't believe in any psychic power.
I've started to say,
okay,
it's fair to say,
but if you just say it that way,
it sounds very cold.
It kind of sounds like I'm an asshole.
I'm a dick.
I'm a skeptic there.
Wait,
wait.
It can't because it means I'm not.
Haven't been open minded.
I am very open minded about these things
and whenever I investigating new
phenomena I opened,
I stepped back,
I put everything that I,
I think that,
hey,
it's not real.
I put that aside and go,
this could be the one.
I'm going to give him a chance,
but I'm going to look at it.
I am going to be a little bit skeptical.
I am going to do a double blind test.
I am going to step back and look at it
from a scientific point of view.
I'm not going to be stupid about this
and I'm not going to let them get away
with something.
And I also know they may be self
deceived and I've seen so much of this
type of phenomena that I usually know
what's going on when I do see it.
So I can honestly say that I've seen so
much phenomena and I've looked at so
much of it and I've seen the best people
out there and I've tested some of the
best people out there that I have not
seen anything indicative.
That psychic phenomena is genuine.
Have you ever heard of anyone who is
reasonably believable that it's seen
anything that counts?
I hear that all the time.
Right?
When you see a John Edward on tv or you
hear these,
these antidotes and stuff like that and
it's just like you're telling me about
Eddie.
So you're telling me that sounds like,
oh wow,
that person could be really psychic,
but I know that there's probably more
going on when that person.
I'm glad you answered the way you
answered because that doesn't make a lot
of sense that yeah,
you did tell stories and people do
forget how the story actually went.
The human memory is very flawed.
Oh,
absolutely.
Why?
We can change a person's memory,
you know,
there's been plenty of experiments that
have done on that.
If you take a certain group of people,
I can't remember what her name is.
It's just not coming to me.
I'm.
I have dyslexia as well,
which is really weird when you see what
I do on stage because I work with
numbers,
I work with names and they use a lot of
mnemonics for these things,
so I really hard time recalling names
and books that I read and stuff like
that.
I just.
It's really hard to come to me,
but it takes a while for those things to
your work.
Like what does it does?
I always thought that it switched things
a girl.
I did it in high school at it.
It does switch things around.
Oh,
it's one of those things like if I'm
working with numbers,
I can't.
I don't even.
I think what it is is I got so
disappointed numbers when I was young.
I love numbers.
I love the fact that everything in the
world,
his numbers I.
I love the idea of numbers of what they
do,
but I think when I was young I would get
so frustrated even in high school and in
middle school I would do math problems,
but I would figure out a way that worked
for me to do the math problem and then
the teacher would come up,
they say like,
show your work,
and I would put it down and they'd say,
no,
that's wrong.
I've got,
but I got the right answer yet,
but that's not the way we do it.
You need to do it this way.
And the normal way of doing things was
extremely difficult for me to switch.
It switches numbers around,
you know,
and if you're trying to switch the
letters for me,
I'll use words that are the wrong words.
I could be talking to you during this
podcast and then I'll listen to the
podcasts and I'll go,
oh my god,
why did I use that word?
You know,
I,
I had a thing where,
um,
I'll give you an example of the type of
things that happened to me.
I have a line when I say,
uh,
in,
in some of my shows where I say,
uh,
I read thoughts,
not minds.
What do I mean by that?
Husband and wife are sitting on a park
bench,
pretty gold goes jogging by husband,
turns his head and looks wife,
slaps the husband in the face.
We know what the husband was thinking.
We know what the wife was thinking,
right?
We haven't read their minds but we do
know what their thoughts are.
So it's sort of that body language
thing.
And I remember one time doing this for a
skeptic's group and I was on stage and I
was like,
husband wife is sitting on a park bench,
pretty girl walks by husband slaps the
wife in the face.
So I said it exactly the opposite of the
way.
And they just thought it was a joke.
Like they thought I was being stupid and
just just a joke.
But I do that kind of stuff consistently
and I have a really hard,
like if you say so a lot of people will
do that,
but it's really bad for me.
Like I do.
I do it consistently,
you'll,
you'll talk about things and I hear you
talk about things and you'll use words
that I actually know what the word
means,
but if I wanted to recall that word and
use it,
cannot remember it,
but what's the mechanism like?
What is happening in your mind where it
switches things around?
I'll call it dyslexia.
I don't know.
For me it's just they call it with me,
it's the effect and it's a really fucked
up word,
right?
For dyslexics to use dyslexia.
Like when they come up with a better
word for that.
It's really hard for dyslexia.
That's the way it is with all that
stuff.
But it's like I got to list,
there's an s in there.
It's like,
why?
Why,
That's true.
Um,
so,
so you,
is there anybody that like,
I mean there's the James Randy
challenge,
right?
Famously were which I was in charge of
the million dollars and I tested many
psychics,
but I guess what I should do is probably
we're in charge of it.
How?
So?
Let's go back to the beginning.
So you understand how I got here on this
journey,
if that's okay.
All right.
And I'll talk about a couple of personal
things in the very beginning.
So I was born in 1960,
so I'm 58 years old,
you know,
so yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
I was born in England,
left there and came to the United
States.
My mom divorced my dad in that year,
went back to England and I'm giving you
this so you understand where I'm coming
from and how I got on this journey.
Uh,
she had two kids.
we immigrated to South Africa in 1969.
She abandoned me in South Africa that
time with my two brothers a year and
three years old.
We had a stepfather who was an
alcoholic.
We saw and maybe on Sundays maybe if I
drag them in from the car into the
house,
we would see him then.
So I was changing diapers.
I was taken care of my brothers and so
forth.
Wow.
Uh,
and I was there until I was 15 years
old.
Now it was during that time that I,
I heard a guy by the name of Eric
[inaudible] who was a famous psychic and
he's the first one to claim that he
could actually been objects with his
mind,
like silverware and became really famous
for it.
He was supposedly a.
They did research with him at standard,
a stanford researcher at Stanford,
Stanford,
Stanford Research Institute,
and he was using that sort of as an
endorsement to say that he was genuine
and one of the things that gala did was
he said if you bring metalogics to the
radio,
you can get them to bend as well.
So I mean,
think about my radio
on the radio.
There was no talking,
there was no tv there at the time.
They had Springbok TV,
they didn't have the actual station,
but they were putting it up and they had
tvs in the store at the time,
but they were playing Papaya,
vhs movies back then,
you know,
on the one.
However they played it back then,
but no TV station.
So that was the thing.
Everybody there listened to the radio
and he's like,
if you bring it to the radio,
you can do it with the unleashed powers
of your mind.
You can get metal,
and so I went around the house.
I found a little pin and my mom's old
sewing kit and I held it up and I looked
at it and I studied it and I
concentrated on it and it bent well on a
micro level.
At least I thought it bends,
so I convinced myself that it had been
my noodly and another that years later,
but in my mind I had got that to happen.
From there I went to Australia to go be
with my biological dad and from there to
Colorado and it was while I was in
Colorado that I picked up a book by
James,
the Amazing Randy and that book said the
truth about Uri Geller.
And in fact the book was changed.
The name was changed years later to the
truth about the truth of Uri Geller from
the magic of Uri Geller.
And that book basically said that early
was a magician posing as a psychic and
no adult had ever told me that before.
All the adults that I did know they
believed in early.
So I believe in is one I learned a
valuable lesson just because people in a
position of authority,
because there are adults that old or new
doesn't make everything they say
correct.
Which I learned it that way.
Um,
because keep in mind I was really
socially inept because I was always
taking care of my brothers.
I had no free time,
so I wasn't hanging out with other kids.
I wasn't doing those things.
I had a great life,
don't get me wrong,
I had a really great life in South
Africa.
I did stupid stuff like jumping off
bridges into trains.
This will,
we get apples,
I have apples to eat at home and stuff
like that.
Jump off the train and take it home.
So those were great things.
Those are great times actually believe
even though it sounds like it's really
sad,
it's not.
So anyway,
I read this book and in the book,
uh,
Randy sort of mentioned eludes to a
method for bending a nail and so I
picked the,
I got some nails,
I started creating my own ways.
I'm sort of a problem solver.
I can you give me something you want to
do and I can go ahead and figure out a
way to do it.
It's why I worked for people like Chris
Angel and you know,
David Blaine open his second TV special
with one of my effects and I'm the first
person to be buried alive six feet on
the ground shaman handcuffed in a coffin
and dig my way to the surface,
which I've done twice and almost died
twice during that.
Um,
but anyway,
getting back on track here.
So we'll get back to that later.
Yeah.
So I to hear about that.
So I wrote,
just gloss over that sir.
I'll gloss over a whole bunch of crap.
I've done crazy crazy stuff where I
should be dead.
I look back now and I go,
I am really.
I mean,
even when I was a kid,
I was crawling down just just,
just to do it.
I'd look at the top story window and I'd
go,
I think I follow down that drain pipe.
I think I can do it upside down and I
would actually climb upside down using
my feet to keep myself up there and
climb down the drain pipe to get down.
So I did a lot of dump,
dump,
dump stuff.
Um,
so I was in high school and I started to
create methods for bending silverware.
So much so that all the kids there went
to plastics are being,
their school actually went to plastic
silverware because all the kids in there
we'll bring in all their silverware to
me.
So we were getting low and silverware.
Um,
they went to plastic silverware.
I got in trouble.
You were bending the silverware with
your mind,
is that what you're saying?
Well,
I was making it.
I was using tricks to make it look like
I was bending it with my mind.
Yeah,
I was crazy.
I was basically doing what Gallo is
doing.
Only the difference was is I didn't
realize it,
but until I saw yellow I was.
I'd never seen Gallo work.
I just heard about him on the radio and
I heard you're supposed to see the metal
band,
so in my mind the effects that I created
to bend metal,
you actually saw the forks and the
spoons and that bending and if you see
any magician working today,
more than likely they're using a couple
of my techniques to make metal look like
it's actually bending A.
I even figured a way to make the school
bell go off so we can get out of school
early.
I got suspended for that.
Why don't you do that?
Because I could know how.
Oh,
how'd you do that?
There was a,
there was a wire and there was a short
that goes through this one classroom
that I was in and I was able to figure
out how to exactly how to get that short
to work with.
The bell would go off and we got out of
school early.
It was just connecting the two and it's
like you and connect.
You connect and it goes off,
so it was like,
Whoa,
okay,
this is great and good that I with the
clock up on the wall,
if you look at a clock,
I realized that as the clock hand goes
around all the way around,
it looks like it's slowing down when it
comes back up.
It's not.
It's just an optical illusion from one
side,
so I would make kids think that I was
making the clock slow down and I figured
a way on an old time timex watch that I
used to be at a way that if I pulled the
stem out and slowly turned it backwards
and pushed it in,
the secondhand would keep moving for
about 35 seconds and then it would just
start like going click,
click,
and then it would stop so I could put my
watching somebody's hands.
So I come up with all these different
methods for accomplishing all these
different feats.
I started learning how to do a thing
called muscle reading,
which we can talk about in a little bit.
Muscle reading.
Yeah.
It's like if it's an old,
old technique that nobody uses and I was
really surprised that people were not
using it,
but it was really,
really popular back in the late 18
hundreds where if you.
If I take your wrist and it's based upon
the idiomotor response,
if I take your risks and I tell you,
look at my other hand and I want you to
imagine it actually touching an object.
Think of one of these objects,
five objects on a table.
Think of my hand actually touching it
and I move my left hand,
which you're not holding here.
Actually I'm holding who you with my
right hand,
but I'm moving your hand in sync with
it.
I will.
If you're thinking,
go to the left,
go to the left or the left.
I can actually feel the resistance when
I go to the right in your arm so you
give off this,
this,
this thing that lets me know exactly
where to go and you could kreskin did it
with his check.
He would hide the check and and before
that polgar did it with his check and
I've done it with my check when I do
shows in the past where they can hide
your check anywhere in the theater.
You take somebody's head and you tell
them to think of my other hand and they
have to know where the objects hidden
and think of that hand actually going
there and touching it and you can
actually find the object.
So I was doing a lot of muscle reading
back in those days and everybody.
What about you get some stone cold
psychopath?
Not No.
They.
They have to really truly be thinking it
and wanting it to happen and that's why
I reframe it in the aspect of you see me
do things with my mind.
I want you to try and do something with
your mind.
Will this hand to actually touch that
object so they do and they don't realize
that subtly there pushing and pulling
you in the right direction and you can
even say them,
don't pull me in the direction.
Let me pull you,
but you're still pulling and pushing
with them and you can find the actual
logic.
And so I wrote a book on it.
It's called psychophysiological thought,
reading psychophysiological
physiological reading,
lot reading,
which is isolating.
I didn't know that.
What I did was we call it bustle,
reading in the business and in the
business.
Yeah.
And I started looking at some of the
older terms for it and I found that term
psychophysiological thought reading.
I thought that's a great name for the
book because every book I've written on
mentalism,
because I write books that teach people
and video I have.
They all start with a pea size series,
you know,
it's,
it's.
Yeah.
So it's all I've talked to,
you know,
I've talked to penn about magic and
about illusions and,
and he's,
you know,
funny about it and he laughs and says
it's all lies and bullshit and you know,
he makes it seem fun,
but the way you described it,
it became a little bit more compelling
because you're,
you're,
you're seemingly obsessed with it.
Like obviously to get as good as you got
at becoming a mentalist like you,
you had to be like,
even the way that you rattle off things
you,
there's very little pause to you.
You stop and start and I talk too fast.
I know everybody says you talk.
We don't talk too fast.
You just talk fast.
Yeah,
I mean I can hear you.
It's very clear.
But that's also what I noticed when you
were doing the reading,
when we did it in front of the crowd of
people and you were able to pick out
certain things that didn't make the air
because it didn't fit the format of the
show at that time.
One of the things,
what,
what Joe Joe's talking about is there's
a part in the show where I ask people
just to think of things.
Um,
and then I start getting initials and
then I get names and then I get,
um,
yeah,
you're,
you're actually thinking about your
grandmother and how you went on a bike
ride with her through certain forests.
Then went to Lake Chelan pull pack and
your birth date is this and that.
And I did a birthday freaking stuff
there.
Yeah.
But it was the weirdest thing is like
they,
they're also overwhelmed by the fact
that you never stopped talking like it
just,
it's just ready go pro.
It just keeps coming like,
Huh,
how do you know that?
And then,
no,
don't,
don't worry about that.
We'll get that to the minute,
you know,
where that comes from.
Jail.
That comes from back in my early days I,
I,
um,
well in the very beginning.
Well let's,
let's get you in with the story.
I'll get to,
I'll get to that to where I work the
places because that sort of comes from
working the comedy clubs and some really
Shitty shitty places and having to grab
people's attention.
Um,
so from there I ended up writing randy
and letter a just out of the blue
because I was getting a little cocky I
guess at young,
you know,
that age because I was getting away with
all this stuff.
And Randy let,
I said,
look,
if you ever need a kid to try to
convince scientists,
this stuff is real,
I would be happy to so long as I come
out and say it's a hoax at the very end.
I had a couple of hypothesis,
um,
and one of them was at scientists
implemented for years.
There's no evidence of the esp on a
proper scientific controls.
And this is back in the eighties because
a lack of funding,
it was my contention had nothing to do
with funding.
You have to do with the scientists were
going with the pro biased opinion and
they would documenting their own beliefs
rather than using proper science.
First of all,
to find out if it was even genuine.
So they were not using the proper
scientific method.
They would basically just saying,
I believe this is real.
I'm going to get it on tape or I'm going
to get it to where I can document it.
So the rest of the world that slowly
down where they biased towards believing
that it was real or fake,
no believing it was real.
Because you don't get.
Usually you don't get into Paris
psychology unless you have an interest
in it and usually you don't have an
interest in it unless you think there's
something there.
Right.
Do those ghost shows drive you fucking
crazy?
Yeah,
they do.
Because I know I've actually been.
I've actually been called to work on a
couple of them behind the scenes that I
always tell them,
no,
I can't do it,
and I have some friends that have worked
on them behind the scenes to try to make
some of the investigators freak and
they're using magic tricks to get the
investigators freak and the great thing
about those kinds of shows is you only
need to do one little thing,
just something falling off a shelf
because it just.
That's all you need,
right?
I mean it's like,
yeah,
there's a ghost.
It fell off the shelf because they play
that tape over and over and over again
and they show a little shadow or
something like that.
There's nothing dumber on television
now,
now and and smarter than I know for a
fact.
There are people that work behind them,
behind those scenes at fooling those
guys.
When we work,
I work with Chris Angel a lot.
Alright.
Uh,
the early days I worked with him on
almost all of his EPA shows.
I've done over a 100 episodes of
television with Chris and we,
every year we would do one episode that
was a silence episode,
that type of thing.
And uh,
we brought a group of researchers in and
the moment they got off the bus,
we had all this stuff set up and
everything else to mess with them.
The moment they got off the bus,
I told my guys,
I said,
we're not using any of that which is
going to use pure psychology with these
people.
And that's what happened because I could
tell they was,
they was such believable.
Anything I suggest to them they're going
to go for.
So let's say we have six rooms and I
need this one room to be the room that
is haunted because that's a story that
goes on behind it with something else
that's already been said and position or
it's got to match up with a bunch of
celebrities who feels something in the
room as well.
All I gotta do is once we go in to,
you know,
you fill anything,
so yeah,
I feel a little haunting.
I feel this and that,
you know,
this room I really want you to take time
with.
That's all I have to say.
And it's the psychics getting headaches
and they just,
they go,
they go crazy because I've already put
it in their head at that point.
Okay.
So the stuff they come up with is going
to be much more believable than any of
the little tricks that we had,
like hidden recordings and stuff like
that.
The stuff they come up with is going to
be much more believable and much more of
a hit.
Are there any real like supernatural
investigators that actually believe in
ghosts or they all come?
People know there's people investigators
that believe in it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
They'll show,
isn't it?
They must know they're fucking think.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
uh,
what is it?
A paranormal state was one of them,
you know,
and,
and I,
I think it's,
some of them are a little abusive too
because they work with little kids
sometimes and they talk the kids into
believing these things and,
and,
and it's just,
some of them are a little bit.
Yeah,
there's a little creepy little creepy
what they do to them and you know,
they usually don't have a psychologist
taking care of the people afterwards to
work them through it and it's just,
it's the psychologist I do is also a
paranormal investigator that believes in
these kinds of things and it's going to
come at it a very slanted angle.
So I've not seen a single one of these
shows that I don't look at it and go
bullshit and just end up turning it off.
So yeah.
Now did they,
I mean,
but is there anybody who like
legitimately,
like anybody who's a reasonable person
who legitimately believes in ghosts and
legitimately believes in every movie,
every haunt horror movie.
There's always like this one real
researcher that there are people like
Lloyd Lloyd,
Alabama,
and you know,
who I know is he believes in this kind
of stuff too.
And you have a tumor.
No,
it doesn't have a tumor
as far as I know.
He does not have it too.
A nice.
He's a nice guy.
I respect a lot of these guys.
I get along with it.
I think you have to,
right?
Because you've got to be at a debate
with these people.
You got to be able to talk to them and
if you show them respect,
they're going to show you reason with
them and sort of explain why what
they're doing is faulty or we,
we have,
we have conversations about certain
things,
certain type of testing,
you know,
and,
and how,
how ridiculous some of these things are.
And,
and,
um,
but you know,
they're going to be convinced that
there's something there.
Even if it's a little little something
like one little thing,
you can't quite knock out a way where
they can do.
I mean,
it's like when I worked with a pat,
so back then Washington University in
1979,
James McDonald gave a half million
dollars to washing university.
All right?
And that was shortly after I had wrote
Randy that let him and now James
Mcdonald,
he was Mcdonald aircraft,
uh,
you know,
the banshee and all those different
types are all named after spirits by the
way.
Yeah.
So if you take,
if you do your research,
you'll find all these things.
So he really truly believed in,
in,
in the afterlife.
And His thinking was,
look,
if they can find something that's even
psychic,
that might be indicative that maybe
there's an afterlife,
you know,
at least it's indicative that something
supernatural paranormal.
There are things we don't understand.
So we gave half a million dollars
washing university,
the form of a laboratory called the
Mcdonald Mcdonald Laboratory for
psychical research short,
we call it Mac lab,
a Peter Phillips there had an interest
in Paris psychology,
but really didn't want to get involved.
But the university said,
look,
we want this money.
We want this lab.
Um,
you believe in this kind of stuff.
You know,
you're interested in San and stuff and
he was a physicist so they put him in
charge.
Uh,
they had over 300 and some applicants
and out of all the,
I sent them a letter out of all the
applicants they had.
There was only two that were accepted.
I mean,
they did some research with other people
there too that they really accepted.
It was myself and another kid that I
didn't know at the time by the name of
Michael Edwards.
Um,
and uh,
Michael turned out to be a magician as
well.
And he had also spoke to randy,
so I get a call.
I said that there was an associated
press article that came out and that's
when I wrote to them and they said,
yeah,
we'd like to,
we'd like you to come visit.
I get a call from randy.
He says,
you know,
there's this guy at Washington
University,
he was being given half a million
dollars to study psychic phenomenon.
Like,
can you just think of his initials for
me?
I said,
is a p and a p?
He said,
how did you know?
I said,
I've already been accepted,
I was going to let you know,
and he started telling me about Mike,
that Mike had already been there.
Mike had been to key in their hands.
They were completely convinced that this
was real psychic phenomena,
but at that point Mike wasn't quite sure
where to take it.
And he knew randy was the expert at the
bunker in the field because randy had
the debunk geller and other psychic
phenomenon.
So he wrote,
he spoke with Randy on the phone and,
and I wrote to randy as well,
and they had some conversations and I
said to randy,
I said,
can I trust Mike?
He says,
I don't know enough about him to trust
him.
And Mike had the same concerns about me
because randy had mentioned me to him
and said,
you should mention,
you know what my real name is Stephen
Shaw.
So it's Steven Shaw back then check came
years later because people couldn't
remember.
Stephen Shaw think you remember a check
because of the.
I say,
here's the LTV.
So I,
I did a corporate gig one day and um,
which is good that you say that.
So I did a Gig one day,
uh,
it was a corporate gig and the guy got
up there and he's like,
either I was really insecure,
you know,
as we already talked about.
So I had my introduction,
here's my introduction.
And uh,
he says I want to do my own
introduction.
You know,
about you.
I've seen you do different things in
that.
So he gets up there and he says,
seen on the today show CNN live.
Um,
he's done this,
he's done that.
I've seen him do this and that.
Please welcome Steven.
What was the last name again?
Sorry.
Great.
So I get up,
I do my Gig,
I got another corporate gig that week.
I get up and say the last guy,
I forgot my name please.
You know,
remember,
my name is Stephen [inaudible].
Stephen Shaw.
Yeah,
I got it.
No problem.
He's done this.
He's done that.
He's on that.
Please welcome Steven.
What was the last name again?
Holy Crap.
It happened to me or third time.
And so I started thinking about why is
this happening and how can I fix this?
Well,
one way to fix it probably I think back
now,
is just say,
hey,
read my thing.
Don't even memorize it,
just read it.
But Stephen is such a common name and
Shaw is such a common name.
There's really no real hard syllables.
And then except for maybe the team at
the va a little bit,
but not really.
It's a soft syllable so it kind of
passes right through the brain.
So they're thinking so much about
everything else they want to say,
you know,
cnn live the today,
show this and that.
I've seen in their story that they want
to tell them everything.
So by the time they get to my name,
they haven't really thought about my
name or memorize my name.
So I wanted a name that had at least two
hearts syllables,
something that would stick in the brain.
And I wanted a one word name,
not a two word name,
one word name,
like a rapper.
Yeah,
this is.
But this is before I'm dating myself.
This was a real wrap prepared.
That's it right there.
So C,
c,
e,
k right there,
and I loved that show.
He was at insurance,
a detective and was that show on?
I don't know.
I think it was only one season,
right?
If I'm not mistaken,
Jamie,
I don't know if you look that up on it,
but I think it was asleep.
Susan right here.
Season one
season.
That was a great show because he always
had these great Polish sayings that
meant absolutely nothing,
but it was just.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Very charismatic in that show.
But the,
the way he sold it was almost like a
magic trick.
It was like they put the statue on the
truck,
the truck arrives and it goes all the
way across the United States and no
statue.
Where did it go?
It turns out that what they actually put
on the truck,
they thought it was a statute because it
was covered and it was in this crate,
but it was a block of ice.
So by the time it got there,
it had already been switched out.
By the time it got there,
it had melted.
So it's sort of magic in its own way as
well.
So I,
it was sort of kindred spirits in a way
to that and I love the name band check
and I was like,
you know what,
if I use banner check the way it's spelt
there,
they going to say Ben Sec.
And so I put B,
a c,
h,
e k,
I didn't want to put an extra seat at
the end because then it becomes bounced
a check or something stupid like that.
So yeah,
I get banana check,
I get bonus check,
you know,
I get all these things but,
but at least here's the thing,
right?
So the old time is back then the ceos of
the company,
the presidents of the company,
if they remember the TV show,
they may make fun of me at first,
but they're going to remember the name
at the end of the show.
They now associate it with me because
I've blown their minds.
If they don't know it,
they've got to come up to me and say,
how do you pronounce that?
So they're thinking about my name.
Never had a problem since.
So there's the old TV show,
banner check,
but the way I spell it,
there was a grey hound a,
there was a dog,
uh,
there was a band called
a check and there was a construction
company.
Now the construction company owned the
bank check earl,
you know,
the website,
but they didn't do anything with it.
So.
And this is back before you could do
automatic payments,
like it just goes every year
automatically for you.
So I would sit there every year just
waiting on that all every day,
you know,
when I knew it was going to go up and I
finally got it.
Like I get after three years of it just
sitting there,
I finally was able to get it.
But yeah.
So anyway,
that's my name,
that's how I got my name.
Okay.
So go back to this Michael Edwards.
So Mike Edwards.
So
I go off on these weird.
I do this all the time.
I go off on so many different tangents
because it's so many different stories
and so many different directions I can
go.
So with Mike,
um,
and,
and you'll find that out in my life.
There is so much psychology applied to
everyday life for me,
like the name,
why did I choose my name?
There was a reason for it.
They say it's not just haphazard and
stuff like that,
or sometimes it's just a joke.
Like,
you know,
I get really sarcastic sense of humor.
Me here.
I go off on another tangent.
All right,
let's go back.
Um,
so here I am with a,
uh,
brandy telling me about them in it and I
said,
Yep,
I've already been accepted.
Mike and I are supposed to show up.
Um,
and by the way,
somebody recently bought my Barry
Sonnenfeld had bought my light life
rights with because of this whole thing,
which is called project Alpha that I'm
telling you the story about now.
And uh,
he had bought it and wanted a Aaron
Sorkin to write it,
but this is way back then.
No,
this is now like not so long.
A couple of years ago,
following up with your timeline,
I know Aaron was.
Aaron was.
Aaron was busy so he couldn't do it.
Uh,
and,
and then when he wasn't busy,
Barry got busy in my life.
Rights.
What they had were basically,
you know,
ran out,
so we've taken it now and I'm working
with another production company to do a
series on what we're talking about right
now.
So,
but anyway,
so here I am,
I'm with Mike Edwards.
We show up at the airport in St Louis.
First Time we get to meet,
we meet each other,
we hit it off right away.
I don't have my driver's license.
I had some form informed idea.
I don't want it for my id.
I had some of the former Id,
uh,
Mike,
he had his and he could drive.
He just got his at the time.
So I wonder if I use my password then.
I don't know.
Anyway,
this whole thing,
you do this,
this fast talking thing.
This is part of the shuck and jive
though.
This is a little bit of me but as I
understand,
but it also is very effective.
That's what a shuck and jive artist
does.
They talk very fast and they never
pause,
so you never get a chance to interject
and they're constantly going.
So if they're reading euro or saying
something,
you have to keep up with them and part
of the keeping up with them as you get a
Little Bit Wilderness and bewildered,
you forget what you've said or they've
said and you're trying to sort of keep
pace with them and you can.
And next thing you know,
they're like,
oh my God,
I can't believe you know that.
How'd you figure that out?
Well,
we'll get to that later and then you
keep going and you keep as part of the
entertainment aspect of it.
Yeah.
It's not what I'm doing right now
because they're sharp as when he was
fighting,
he would put a piece on you you couldn't
keep with,
right?
Yeah.
See,
you always analyze it with fighting,
which is great.
It's kind of that thing.
Vulnerabilities and exploit
vulnerabilities in the human mind.
They.
One of them is that you talk and think
faster than most people.
So most people when you're talking,
they don't have it.
Right.
You just did right there.
You want to get a chance to interject
because I'm gonna keep talking and as I
keep talking I talk quicker and you get
bewildered.
That's one of the things that you do to
people,
whether you realize it or not,
you do it because you've done it that
way for a long time.
It's probably become a pattern,
has become a pattern to make the other
person feel unsecure so you don't know
what you're paying for.
It's a patent for me being able to think
and not forget things as I'm saying them
like because like as you so effective
that you said that.
There is another thing that popped in
my.
I got like all day long.
I have songs in my head.
It doesn't stop.
Like I,
I do this with my teeth all the time.
Playing the music in my head like
constantly.
If I'm not thinking about anything else,
I have songs in my head constantly and
I've even.
I went to the dentist and I said,
Hey,
I've got this thing with my teeth and
I'm tapping my teeth.
I'm wearing him down.
You know what's going on?
And he says,
oh,
musicians do that all the time.
I go,
well,
I always have music 24 hours a day in my
head.
So wow.
But now I've gone off somewhere and they
would say,
oh,
the handwriting.
So if you look at my hand,
look my hand writing how bad my head,
right?
Like it's really hard to freaking read.
Right?
But it's not that bad.
Somebody just wrote me a letter and I
read the letter.
Somebody,
a friend of mine sent me something.
He wrote me a letter and I've read his
letter.
I was like,
well what the fuck is that?
Because it's just scribbled.
Well that's me writing neat.
So slow.
Normally when I write I can't read it
myself.
I.
Well that's the thing,
what you just said,
you,
you're trying to keep up with your
thoughts.
Yeah.
And that's one of the things about bad
handwriting.
They say that you're trying to keep up
with what you're thinking and learning.
It's always going a mile a minute.
It's a thousand different ways.
And I think it's part of my problem
solving is like when people give me
ideas that they want,
okay,
this is what I'd like to do as a magic
effect.
How do I do it?
I'm able to rattle off like 10,
15 different.
But it's like as a mentalist that way
that,
that pattern of talking is so
bewildering to people that they just
sort of like,
Huh,
what?
What?
Huh?
And you've got them on the ropes.
Always is that thing of even in my state
show.
And you'll have to come to the state
Something I would love.
I would love you to come see the mini
version of it.
When you did the television show,
I was blown away.
I mean,
the first thing I do is I come out
before I don't even introduce myself.
Where did you do it?
So if people can what they want to see.
I was just at Planet Hollywood filling
Vegas.
Yeah.
I've got a,
uh,
a thing coming up,
at Rochester,
a fringe festival in Rochester,
New York.
I mean,
I'm at a lot of different college.
You can go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com and look up the
dates,
but the Rochester is going to be a on
the 13th at 7:00 PM.
40th 5:00 PM that I'm on the 20th at
9:00 PM,
2:23 PM.
I know.
So you can find it on the path.
You can't even help yourself.
You can find it on them.
You're going to find it on the website.
So it is on the website yet,
but you're in vegas all the time.
Right?
I'm in Vegas a lot.
Work Vegas that much.
I'm busy now really until I'm beginning
of November.
I'm going to be like different places.
Just touring,
touring different places.
Some of it's corporate,
some of it's college,
you know,
it's a mixture of a mismatch of
different,
different things.
So go back to this whole James,
Randy,
Uri Geller.
So here I am with a Mike Edwards at the
airport and we're hitting it off and
everything.
Peter Phillips shows up and he's the
professor that I mentioned a minute ago
who's going to be doing the
investigating of us and he has this
wristband on and I'm always asking
questions.
What's this,
what's that?
And I'm always noticing things and he
said it was a wristband that he got from
a witch doctor in Africa that helps
protect him.
So I'm starting to think this might be a
little easier than I thought it was
going to be going in.
I was like,
I didn't know these guys skeptical.
They give you these one way.
Mirrors.
Are they gonna be trying to trick us,
catches.
I had no clue.
So we get into,
uh,
we were,
we had Peter Phillips,
his car because Mike was too young to
drive a rental.
Peter Phillips has at Rental Reynolds in
front of us who were following him.
And this is,
this is how it all starts.
Really.
I'm sitting there and just kind like be
talking all the time.
I'm looking around,
I'm always doing something.
Always noticing something.
I look in the backseat and I noticed as
a briefcase I reached in the back and I
kind of pull it under the Dash.
It's locked into me.
Like if somebody locked something,
it means they don't want you inside
there.
Of course.
Right.
But why does anyone is in their old
briefcase easily.
You can just open the locks.
So I pick the locks,
open it up inside.
There's a whole bunch of silver.
So either this guy's a Kleptomaniac or
this is a civil right.
He's going to be using for the
experiments.
So I stopped bending it all up,
lock the briefcase,
put it in the back,
sit there for about two more minutes,
open up the glove compartment,
this extra keys and things in the glove
compartment.
I stopped bidding those up instead his
fucking keys.
I ha.
Well I'm a psychic,
right?
This stuff happens to those keys and
getting his house.
Yeah.
But I needed him to be convinced that
was genuine.
So I ended up looking over the car keys
that are hanging out,
the keys that are hanging out on the
car.
Key out of the ignition.
I start to reach over to get them.
And Mike just looks at me and says,
I think you've done enough.
Stop.
You know.
So.
But there's this really interesting
phenomenon,
right?
We knew that in the laboratory,
everything we did at that point was
going to be on a micro level.
It's going to be very small because it
had to be because we couldn't make it
look like it's a trick.
We had to look like my newt and not just
that.
We didn't know if they were going to be
watching it.
Like I said,
through one way mirrors and things like
that,
so this interesting phenomenon at the
time that was called spontaneous pk and
that is stuff that just happened.
Hey Pete psychokinesis PKA shorter for
the sector cases,
telekinesis,
psychokinesis,
the whole thing.
They all have the same thing,
so there's these things just supposedly
happened around these psychics that can
bend metal stuff,
moves,
stuff breaks that.
So those things were the things that
would convince him and keep him holding
on.
Even if we did a big band out of the
laboratory but not on camera.
That's the thing that would keep him
going.
I want to get that on film.
I definitely want to get that on film.
I'm going to document that someday.
That's going to happen in the
laboratory.
When we ended up getting to the
laboratory,
all the students at the university were
extremely skeptical,
very,
very skeptical,
but they had heard about the spontaneous
pk,
so they hit things under neath,
the video recorders in it.
There was a separate room and they hit
all kinds of things everywhere around.
I noticed there was stuff hidden.
I mean,
why is it recorded?
Had none of that VCR,
you know,
why is there a fork hidden behind that
cupboard,
you know,
it doesn't belong there.
So I started bending up all those things
on lunchtime and that convinced all the
students that we were genuine as well.
So this,
this,
this whole thing went on and on.
It's a simple as.
So what happened was immediately randy
sent them a list of 13 caveats things
that we,
that they shouldn't do,
and it was common sense stuff,
right?
It was stuff like,
don't let the subjects work at the same
time because they could distract you.
Don't let them work with more than one
object at a time because they could
confuse you with those objects as to
which ones you bending and there was
this whole list of different things.
They showed the list to me and Mike and
had a good laugh about it and said,
this would make you guys so
uncomfortable.
We want you to be comfortable where in
reality they should have followed that
list because one of the things randy
said was mark everything on a micro
micro and a macro level so they the
subjects can see the macromark but won't
realize as a micro mark on there as
well,
which would have helped because their
idea of doing a macro mark was on every
fork.
They took the fork or spoon.
They measured it at both ends,
like the height from the table and they
measured the middle of the four from the
height from the table.
Then they put a label on it on a little
string with a number on it and that was
her idea of keeping track of if
something had bent on.
Not because they would measure it after
we concentrated on it and they would
then remeasure it again afterwards and
they would say,
oh,
okay,
this is a.
This has been a millimeter or two
millimeters.
So we would do things like,
we would say,
this tags in my way.
Can I take it off?
Yeah,
you can take it off.
We put it down,
concentrate on it,
didn't do anything.
Put it down on the table,
pick up another fork or spoon.
Say,
do you mind if I remove this tag?
Take it off,
put it down,
concentrate on it.
Nothing happens.
Switched the tags around on the one that
was on the first one to the second one,
the second one of the first one,
and then put the two folks off to the
side and then wait two,
three hours later,
pick up one of those forks.
Obviously not doing anything with it.
Concentrating on it.
Say,
why don't you measure it,
and they would measure it and the
measurements had now changed not
realizing because they never measured
the other one again because I remembered
everything consistently later on and put
new tires on them.
Every single time,
not realizing that we just simply
switched forks or as we reached across
the table,
we would lean on one of the forks and
then ours again later we would pretend
like we actually bought that for.
So this went on.
I mean it went on for 180 hours over
four years.
I mean,
we messed with these people bad.
We did probably some things at the time
that were probably illegal as well,
like leaving the window unlocked at the
laboratory,
going off to the club across the state
line,
coming back like about four or 5:00 in
the morning,
break it into the building and bending
up every single piece of metal that was
in the laboratory.
They had a fucking scientists.
We're running this.
Well,
this is back in the eighties.
So.
Right.
And they,
they had,
they actually had this aquarian back in
the 80 scientists were like eighties TV
shows.
No,
it's true.
And here's the sad thing,
right?
I went into this thinking these people
were going to be the enemy.
It was me against them.
You know,
I had to do this.
Turns out these are just really,
really nice,
nice people that are very naive when it
comes to what psychic phenomena as well.
If you're a scientist,
most likely you're not studying a whole
lot of liars and mentalist magicians and
psychic phenomenon and you really are
probably trying to find out whether or
not it's real and maybe you believe a
little bit too much.
You don't know enough yet when it came
to this type of phenomena.
Absolutely.
But you gala was already doing that.
Other psychics are already doing it in
other countries and they will be
invalidated as a genuine thing in other
countries.
Yeah.
We brought over in France,
Steven North over in England,
you know,
there was a lot of research going on in
England at the time on this type of
phenomena as well.
It was a really big thing back then.
It was just people hosing people.
It was a little kid.
So here's a weird thing,
right?
So over in England there were,
um,
I can't think of what the guy's name is
now.
Uh,
there was a scientist over there,
a pair of psychologist who was working
with little kids,
and his thinking is that kids don't lie.
Little kids don't lie.
That's all they do is lie.
They get to that point where they
learned how to lie to get anything and
everything.
Kids don't lie.
That's someone without kids.
And these kids only got caught.
The only reason they got caught,
which by accident because they were the
video cameras are left on and soon as
the Paris psychologist left the room,
the kids were taking forks and spoons
and actually bending them underneath
their feet and then putting them back up
on the,
on the table.
So then they would come in.
It was literally scientists went in with
the premise that children don't lie.
That is one of the dumbest fucking thing
I've ever heard in my life.
Don't disagree with you,
but this is how badly people wanted to
believe in this phenomenon.
Why do people want to believe in hidden
powers?
I think it's white.
People want to believe in most things,
right?
I mean,
we want to find,
we want to believe there's something
more than just us,
like for most people we're just,
we're not enough and I don't know if
it's because we get so bored with our
lives,
we get depressed without lies,
we get,
you know,
we're in this everyday thing of going to
work,
coming home.
And is this all there is,
is this,
that,
you know,
is there something else that,
that's a super power that I could,
I could actually have.
Is there something I can discover that's
bigger than me?
Better than me,
you know,
does this a units versus much bigger
than just this planet right here.
Right.
So,
I mean if you asked me,
I think that
if you,
if a Ufo is,
we'll come in here.
If they were coming here,
let's say,
I don't believe they were,
but if they were coming here you don't
believe they were.
But I think if they,
I just don't,
I,
I don't.
I think we would really have real
evidence.
One hundred percent evidence of it by
now.
But here's the thing,
right?
Wouldn't it make much sense?
Even like for us?
Okay,
let's say we start going looking at
other planets,
are we going to send other humans out
there or are we going to go ahead and
send robots or something like that?
They can last much.
Yeah,
like in the last month and robots are
getting better and better and better.
So if there's an advanced civilization,
civilization,
surely they would also have this
advancement where they don't have to
send themselves out.
They can send something to represent
them.
Right.
What the real hardcore believers believe
those grades are gray aliens.
The big black eyes.
They think there's some sort of a
android or something and it could be,
but I don't believe.
I don't believe we had him.
I believed a lot more before I started
doing that television show.
The television show cured me of bigfoot,
cured me of psychics,
cured me of aliens,
cured me of almost everything.
Well,
this is a thing with me,
right?
When I was a young kid,
I believe in that stuff.
You know,
when I was a young kid,
I spoke in tongues.
I thought they did.
Yeah.
I had the whole experience.
I mean,
it was like,
you know,
all the chemicals running through my
body and me just
doing the whole damn thing,
you know,
and go into that.
And I realized later what was going on
at the time I was looking for answers.
I was looking for answers.
So you mentioned that a very disturbed
life and you're probably looking for
some sort of security.
I got shut down every single time I
would ask the questions.
I was called a troublemaker,
you know,
oh,
we're talking about darkness and evil.
Oh,
well how come the Bible's covered in
black to shut up?
Don't ask questions.
You know,
I've written black.
What do you mean?
Well,
you know,
the cover of most of the bibles back
then we didn't have the white bibles.
We all had the black bibles and it was
just,
I would just ask innocent questions
like,
okay,
well how can I,
if,
if you're talking about darkness being,
you know,
an evil and you're,
it's all associated.
Why is this Bible covered in black?
You know,
and I just wanted answers,
was looking for answers.
I would ask these questions and I do
that.
I,
I thirst knowledge,
I love knowledge,
you know,
I read all the time.
It's just I'm always looking to try to
understand things.
I won't always retain all that
information,
but it'll be in the back of my head
somewhere where it will pop out at some
point when I do need it.
So.
But it is fascinating.
This desire to believe,
especially the desire to believe things
that don't necessarily make sense.
Whether it's ghosts or it's Ufos or do
you ever watch that show?
Finding bigfoot?
I have in the past.
It's not something I sit down and binge
it,
but every episode is like a rock got
thrown or this same as these gaucher
like that every week nothing happens,
but somehow they managed to keep you
glued to your seat.
I think you watch it.
People watch it because they think,
oh,
this is going to be the show.
This is going to be the one because they
tease it like that.
But here's the thing,
right?
If it was the one we would have already
heard about it before it got to air.
The key is night vision.
Once you have night vision,
you seem legit.
He looking for things in the basement.
Are you looking for things in the woods?
If you have night vision or thermal
visions,
like something.
Oh,
technology.
They'll find it now where it's like the
ghost detecting meters,
so it's a little meetings.
You can set them off just by hitting a
walkie talkie.
Oh,
you can?
Oh yeah.
Like way across the room or in another
room.
You had a walkie talkie.
Those things go freaking crazy.
You know,
in the in paranormal research.
Is there like a moment?
Where.
Do you know that in Seti?
Search for extraterrestrial
intelligence.
There's A.
There's this one phenomena that
happened.
I think they call it the blip or
something like that.
Yeah,
I don't think that's the name.
I think it was either.
There's this one
or whatever it is.
There's one loud noise that came from
space that they think is.
They don't know what it is.
They're not sure what that was,
so you know what?
I'm conflating it with something that
happened under water.
That's what I'm doing.
There was something.
There was an organic noise that was
underwater.
It wasn't the signal that's the cold,
the bloop,
whatever it was.
There's a steady thing like that.
There is a steady thing like that too,
but I'm.
I,
I confused the two events that there was
something that happened where they
recorded an organic sound underwater
from some sort of an animal that they
don't know what it was,
but they think it could be a whale or
something.
Who knows?
Just something could be something you
discovered you hadn't seen yet.
I mean,
it's a lot of stuff under there we don't
know about for sure.
Big Place.
Yeah.
When we're talking about the desire for
people,
I mean this is what one of the reasons
why being a mentalist works or being one
of these psychic hoaxers works is
because people have this overwhelming
desire to believe there's something more
out there and not just the powers that
you and I possess the normal sense of
seeing and hearing and touching and
smelling and d,
but there's more.
Some people have more,
some people knowing the phone's going to
ring.
Some people know things.
They have an intuition.
They could sense rs.
Some people.
No,
hold on,
hold my hand.
Let me look in your eyes.
I know things.
I know.
Things you don't know.
It's like the creepy how you're looking
at me right now.
Just weird.
That's a weird thing,
right?
But that's what the desire because it
gives us a white.
Why would somebody be looking at me like
that if there wasn't a purpose and if
you believe in if there wasn't something
when I perform,
I don't just read minds.
I,
I do things like I touch their hand,
I seen him look at me,
see this right there,
and I do certain things because it's
that thing of like I've got to show a
process and if I'm showing a process,
why would I be showing a process if it
wasn't real?
Now here's the weird thing was so
overwhelming them with things to think
about.
Yeah,
to a point.
I know we you touching them and moving
them or looking at them as all these
variables they have to take into account
and they're on their map of things that
they're processing.
That's now some new territory.
Yeah,
it,
it also.
We talked about this earlier.
We got to come.
We've got so many stories all over the
place.
We stopped at that.
I'll try to come back to some of them,
but it's back in my comedy club days.
I worked the worst and the best clubs.
I mean that was at the comedy workshop
in Houston,
Texas.
I don't know if you remember them on.
Sure.
Paul Solos,
Sharon,
and they
had me come and do a Christmas show
because I wanted a clean show for
Christmas and I came in and then they're
like,
all right,
you're going to go out in the road and
you're headlining.
Like straight off headlining.
No middling,
no,
no opening act,
nothing.
I went straight into headline in which a
lot of comedians hated me for that
because they're working so hard to get
and it's like there's no place for magic
in a comedy club.
It's a comedy club,
but I was going out.
I was doing these comedy clubs,
but I was doing like the best and I was
also doing the worst,
like I always doing comedy clubs where
literally it's a kick a bar in a,
uh,
an oil town and there's Mesh like in
blue brothers,
you know,
across the front because people throw
beer bottles at the band and everything
else and I'm performing behind that with
a little gate that they have to come in
for me to perform with these people with
a big pole in the middle because people
kick her dance around that and the bar
is actually around the corner and I got
to try and get people in that.
So I performed at the worst and the best
places I performed in situations where
people were just not there to see the
performer there.
You know,
at colleges where it's a,
a day show and day,
a mandate shows are the worst in
colleges.
The worst if you've done them.
Yeah.
Like you come in,
it's like they're sitting in the
cafeteria.
You are performing the cafeteria,
they're trying to study for a test.
They're not there for you.
So I got to grab their attention.
So my first thing is to come out and
say,
if I was to ask everyone to think of a
playing card,
you might think ace of spades,
queen of hearts,
I want everyone to think of a car.
I'd get one,
get one,
stand up.
And it's like Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
It where it's like,
holy crap,
we need to pay attention to the sky.
And so that's where I came in from those
harsh days.
Really just trying to grab their
attention with comedians.
Do Bar gigs.
Yeah,
you just got to,
you got to quiet them down.
You got to go to grab him.
So anyway,
so I'm with the scientists.
Uh,
we break in,
in the laboratory at night.
Uh,
they have an aquarium,
there's another psychic there that
supposedly gets ghosts to come in and
the ghost will write things in these
coffee grounds,
in this inverted aquarium,
a with a padlock on it.
And there's bars that go over it.
My Kid,
the other kid that's with it looks
underneath and realizes that the,
even though it's locked on top,
the post that it's locked to those nuts
underneath it,
like bolts,
he just unbolted it,
lifts it up.
We write stuff in the coffee grounds,
we bolt it back up and you know,
so it's like all these things and we
bend everything.
Uh,
we go to bed about five in the morning
and uh,
Peter Phillips calls and he calls it
about seven in the morning.
He says,
how you doing?
I said,
oh,
I didn't sleep well last night.
I had a dream that we were in the
laboratory,
you know,
trying to work and everything just bent
and went crazy.
He said,
well,
go back to sleep.
I'll talk to you in a few hours.
He calls me back in about another hour.
He says,
you did it,
you did it.
You did it.
And I go,
what did we do?
He goes,
you know,
he says,
your psychic powers when you were
sleeping,
bent everything in the laboratory.
So it was just,
we play these games.
We did these live.
He's still alive.
I've met him since then,
feel tricked him.
He felt,
well,
here's the thing,
I felt bad.
So we were talking to randy at one point
because,
um,
we did a conference and there's a kid by
the name of muscle,
walkie Chiodo.
Alright.
Uh,
from Japan,
Masa walkie could speak English.
She had a band that he was in as well.
Um,
so we sang English songs and everything
and I'm rooming with him and I say to
muscle walkie Kyoto because he's playing
it up for real,
like,
you know,
and I say,
is there anytime when you can't do your
psychic powers,
you use a trick.
And he says,
oh,
can't speak English,
cannot speak English.
All of a sudden he couldn't speak
English.
So with this gallows at the thing as
well.
Um,
and the reason I mentioned muscle walk
is because there was a TV producer from
England that came over and he said to
randy,
said,
what would convince you that this stuff
is genuine?
Rainy,
gave him the same 11 caveats that he
gave to the scientist,
the same 11 carrots.
And uh,
the guy followed them.
He sat with me.
He sat with Mike,
he sat with muscle walkie up the muscle
walk.
He had a way for twisting a spoon and
basically had a thing in his shoe.
He would go down and when nobody was
looking,
put it in there,
but because this guy followed the 11
caveats,
nothing happened that day.
Absolutely nothing happened until the
cameras went off.
The moment the cameras went off,
muscle walkie twist that a spoon and
started getting it to twist.
The producer had a complete mental
breakdown.
Now,
to this point,
I'm just thinking,
this is tricks,
right?
It's not.
It's not that big of a deal.
He starts screaming,
yelling that randy's evil should never
have listened to randy.
He would've got this on tape if it
wasn't for Randy and he looks down and
he's got a wet spot on the front of his
pants and he looks down and he says,
I just had a demonic ejaculation,
like literally,
and he's having his mental breakdown.
I go and I have to spend the night,
which was not a bad thing.
She was quite pleasant to look at his
his assistant.
I had to spend the night with her in her
room because randy was calling her.
I'm not randy.
I mean,
uh,
Tony editable calling of the producer
was calling her consistently screaming
and yelling about randy and this scared
them.
Hold the fuck up.
You can't just gloss over the fact that
guy just noted in his pants and he was
yelling,
you just had a mental.
It's a mental breakdown,
orgasm and your pants during a mental
breakdown.
I didn't do it.
He did it that you should document that.
That's more present than bending a
spoon.
I should've said,
yeah,
that's my psychic ability working right
there.
I mean,
that doesn't make any sense.
So he tells you this as an ejaculation.
His pants.
He in front of everybody.
He says it's a demonic ejaculation.
East.
Straight up says I added the Arctic
ejaculations.
Seems like a together guy with
definitely got a head on his shoulders.
Was a producer for us.
I think it was BBC,
if I'm not mistaken.
He was doing a documentary for them,
so yeah.
Well,
he's fucking crazy.
Huh?
He finished.
He finished a documentary,
so.
Oh,
well yeah,
definitely.
It wasn't crazy then.
As long as you finish this documentary.
Well,
he believed in psychic phenomena.
He believed that the demon made them
come in his pants.
That is true,
yes.
As show it to you as to whether he
believed it was a demon or not.
I don't know.
Demons.
Demonic.
Ejaculate.
When your parents,
what do you like?
Pull your shirt down.
Like get out of there.
I think I wouldn't dating that demon.
I mean probably the price to pay that.
You wouldn't want that.
Don't need a girlfriend.
Donate a woman at that point.
Grants when disagreement and yellow.
It's a good looking demon.
So he was saying that randy was evil
because if it wasn't for Randy's rules
that he would not.
He would have got this on tape.
But how dumb does that guy have to be?
I mean that is so silly.
Like this is a person that's supposed to
be discovering or at least investigating
psychic phenomena and he doesn't
understand that investigator,
right?
He's a producer.
He's a producer who believes in this
phenomena.
Hence he wants to do a documentary on
psychic phenomena.
Has an interest in it.
He already believes in it,
so he's not,
he's not as bad as the,
the Paris psychologists who are supposed
to be using proper science because I'm
often asked,
is it right?
Is it ethical that you full scientists
in the name of science?
Right?
So this becomes this whole big question
like,
uh,
we will be unethical to do that.
Um,
and my aunts that did that in a minute,
who the fuck asked you that question?
A lot of scientists say that fools.
Well,
and it's a thing,
right?
Because if you think that they do,
it's like,
yeah,
if you ask a guy who's a thief to break
into your house and then he breaks into
your house in a method that with a
method that you didn't anticipate,
is that unethical?
It's no different than what you're
doing.
You're,
you're a mentalist.
you're a person who is trying to trick
them.
They have all these rules setup to make
sure that you don't trick them.
So they know for a fact that what you're
doing is psychic energy.
But if you don't really have psychic
powers and you absolutely don't,
of course you're going to fucking trick
them.
The idea that you would trick them and
that would somehow or another be
unethical.
No,
you just played the game better than
them.
Well,
this was,
this was the point,
right?
It was this thing of like,
uh,
my thing was,
should you be taking money to
investigate this phenomena under false
pretenses because you're not using
proper science if you're using proper
science.
I won't get away with any of this.
Had you have followed brandy's rules,
we would not have got away with any of
this.
I mean,
we had very strict ethical rules.
If you ask us,
if we magicians,
we have to say yes.
If you ask us if we're working for the
amazing randy with him,
you have to say yes.
You know,
so we have all these rules.
Those old TV shows where like if someone
was an undercover cop and say,
are you a cop?
They have to tell you that they don't
really have to do that,
that that's they don't know.
That's the only premise they use really
shows a damn it.
Have you asked a cop,
are you a cop?
And they go,
no,
and then you buy the heroin off him.
Them still go to jail.
Wow.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I'm going to go buy heroin or anything,
but you know there may be something
else.
I'll say something about a gun.
Yeah.
There's very few people that have told
me a story where I go,
damn,
I wish I was there for that story,
but the nuts and the pants and blaming a
demon,
I really do wish I was there.
I really wish I was there for that guy.
I like to be in the room and I'd be
like,
hold up.
Everything else.
Just going to get put on the back burner
here.
Nowadays it'd be like,
hold on,
let me get my smartphone out.
I got to take a picture on instagram.
Demon and why are you showing me?
You're just so parents.
How much do you have to come?
And your pants were chosen.
The
outside,
Jesus Christ.
We was scared though.
Like kids like we will,
we will kill you.
So probably towards the end 19 would've
been about 1981.
Nineteen 82.
That means I'm 21,
22,
somewhere in that area.
You could probably still kick
[inaudible] ass.
Yeah.
But keep in mind I was also a kid who
was very like socially and like not.
I mean I'm the kid in the back of the
class when the heavy coat on in the
middle of winter.
Was that the first time a guy that ever
came in his pants and then pointed to it
in front of me as well?
For me?
Yes.
That's never happened my whole life.
I can never say I've ever had that
happen.
Know ever.
I like to go to my grave without anybody
ever nothing in their parents.
And then pointing down,
go look at Damon made me do this.
Or you have an excuse now if it ever
happens to you.
Well now the problem is millions of
people have heard this and so they'll
just scan me.
So I'm going to run into people.
Everywhere you go,
you guys are going to pull their shirt.
He goes to work at a comedy comedy.
Be 10 guys,
stand up with a puddle pointing down
with a little bit.
It's going to be great day.
Maybe not in my pants.
Did you bring nails?
Man?
I did.
I brought Nelson.
I got.
I got some stuff.
Maybe we might get to some of that
stuff.
I have it.
I have stuff here in case.
So you felt bad that you trick this
dummy with Mike and I really like.
We were scared because we realized the
kind of.
He was unhinged.
Not that we realized the kind of power
we had over these people at that point
it was just them,
but it's like there's another whole
thing going.
This whole psychological thing going on
here because they want to believe so
badly.
Really messing with people's heads,
right?
I mean we're really.
And what's going to happen?
We come out and say this is all a fraud
and fake.
So we sat down random.
He said,
look,
we want to come out and we want to end
it now.
And he was like,
you know what?
We got a TV show.
We're going to be coming up in a couple
of months.
Let's just wait and expose it then.
It's not gonna make any difference.
So we,
we hung out until that time.
I mean,
there was a peripheral,
you know,
scientists and there was one guy with
any of that birth or swartz.
I didn't want to do anything with him
because he kind of came into the scene
at the end of working with the Mac lab,
but he kept pushing and pushing and
pushing and he lived in New Jersey.
So finally I went out there and this guy
kind of believed in everything it was.
It was.
He wrote a whole book called the,
uh,
tanning,
the poltergeists of the poultry taming
Tammy.
I mean,
the guys you can find it online as well.
And it was a booklet and it was a,
it was for the psychosis psychosis
dynamic,
uh,
something like as a,
something of dentistry and medicine,
but it was an actual medical journal and
it was all about his stuff that he had
done with me.
Um,
but this guy believed in everything.
Like,
he handed me a camera one time,
uh,
a video camera and he said,
look,
I've,
uh,
I,
I knew a lady that could take pictures
of the sky and when I get the film and
you know,
I get it developed and I look at it and
I play it,
you can see Ufo is in the sky that you
couldn't see with the naked eye.
Can you do that?
Now?
I was one of these kids that I was just
like,
I would say I could do anything and
everything.
Even in the laboratory I would say I
could do anything.
And um,
so he hands me the camera.
I start taking pictures of the parking
lot in the sky and everything and I hand
it back to him.
So he gets it developed when he gets
developed.
This is vacation footage and then
there's him handing me the camera.
You see all of a sudden this weird kind
of blog.
And in the blob you see a woman's torso
and thigh.
You see a woman giving birth to a baby.
You see Jesus Christ,
you see all these images and he,
uh,
he,
he pointed them out to me.
I could see them as well when you
actually pointed Aurora Shark test,
that kind of thing.
Sort of.
Yes,
because this guy's affording
psychologists.
All right,
so we'll,
all I had simply done was I,
I didn't know what to do.
I was just making stuff up as I went
along.
So I spat on the front of the camera and
that Blob as it changes and as it dried,
almost like looking at clouds,
you could see all these different
shapes.
And so he believed that this was psychic
phenomena.
This was something that was happening.
Now I got to give the Mac lab credit
because when Peter Phillips said,
saw it,
he said,
yeah,
it looks like a blob of water and,
and,
but,
but birth always said to him,
he said,
yeah,
but it's what's in the blog that's
important.
It's what you see inside that's
He called me up one day.
I lived in Pennsylvania.
Then he called me up one day and said,
you did it.
You did it.
And I said,
what did I do?
He said,
well,
there's this jar,
and there was this one jar that he would
have silverware and things inside,
and they were all sealed and he would
have sitting up on a shelf and it's 7:00
every night I was supposed to
concentrate and never did,
but I was supposed to concentrate from
Pennsylvania and get the try to get the
stuff to ben long distance.
And he calls me up.
He said,
you know that Joe,
you concentrate every night.
Yep,
I know that you are.
He said,
you did it.
And I'm thinking,
damn,
I'm good.
Oh,
what the hell happened here?
He says,
well,
you actually missed it,
but you hit the radiator and it's
leaking all over the floor.
So he believed that's how much this guy
believed in all this stuff and gave me
credit.
But when you read it,
here's the interesting thing,
right?
You know what I mean?
He stuck electrodes on my head.
He did all kinds of psychological tests
and the psychological tests turned out
that if I wasn't psychic,
I would be crazy.
So those tests,
his,
his psychological tests for me show that
if I wasn't like psychic I would be
crazy,
but I was asking and answering the
questions like a psychic,
like a psychic wooden.
So Berthold Schwartz was a,
another character and at the very end
when we came out and said this was all a
fraud,
it was all a fake.
Berthold was the one that said amongst a
couple of other people,
but he was the primary one that said,
look,
they say they were lying,
then how do we know they're not lying
now?
Oh good.
Which is an interesting question,
right?
But my answer,
because I can show you how I did those
things.
Even the Mac lab,
they,
we had a conference in the time life
building in New York where we came
clean.
He said it was all a hoax we got up
there and if you can ever find footage
of this online,
it's great because randy introduces us
and it's time life building.
Everybody's there.
I mean,
you know,
discover magazine,
psychology today.
Uh,
you know,
the New York Times,
everybody,
everybody from all over the world there.
And they think Randy's found two
psychics that are genuine and we get up
there and we demonstrate stuff.
And then Randy's,
you know,
somebody asks the question,
how do you do it?
And Randy looks at us,
he says,
you want to answer Mike?
So Mike Edwards walks over,
he says,
Yep.
He said,
it's a hoax,
it's a trick.
And then I say,
yeah,
for the last four years we've been
fooling the scientists and that's when
we came out and you see that mouse open.
I like,
oh my God,
you know,
it's,
it's just,
it's great.
Great footage when you could see it
because it's that moment,
the scientists would not answer that
phone until we spoke to them.
And I have the recording,
I have jay had the recording of where I
ended up calling them back and I'm
recording the conversation and I,
he says,
we've heard this rumor that you guys are
working with Randy and that you're not
real.
And I say,
what do you think?
And he says to me,
that can't be true.
It has to be real.
And I go,
well,
unfortunately it is true.
And he starts asking,
well,
how did you do this?
And then I tell him how did you do that?
And I tell him and he's constantly
asking about this and that,
trying to find one thing,
one thing that he could hold onto.
And there was some little things because
a lot of times when you have real
information and you know you're going to
be to do something,
you take chances and sometimes those
chances hit as well.
So you can't explain that.
That's just the odds,
right?
Yeah.
So he wanted desperately to believe.
And the thought was that maybe you had
psychic powers but you didn't want
people to know you at psyche power so
that you trick them.
And then you were lying afterwards to
conceal your power.
Right.
He also mentioned that Randy May have
paid us off to life for him too.
So yeah.
Well he was probably devastated,
right?
Because as a scientist,
I'm sure he was.
He,
he caught a guy that I knew in
Washington,
Pennsylvania where I lived,
and I think the guys still lives there
now,
but it had been the name of Joe newsome
and Joe was an escape artist and I knew
Joe now,
keep in mind when I was doing all this,
I really didn't know any magicians.
In fact,
even when I started out,
I didn't know there was an area of magic
call mentalism,
which is doing,
you know,
taking your five senses to create the
illusion of a sixth sense.
You not a psychic,
you're using tricks using psychology,
verbal,
nonverbal communication,
but mostly magic to create these tricks.
All right.
I knew,
I didn't know that.
I just knew there were people that con
people with tricks to make them think
they were psychic.
That's all that I knew at that time.
But I met a few magicians and one of
them was Joe newsome.
So birth Schwartz caught up,
Joe.
He said,
why would,
why would steve do this?
Why would I do this?
Um,
and Joe says,
I don't know,
but I could open the locks with my mind.
Joe Proceeded,
which I thought was a really asshole
thing to do.
Joe Proceeded to work with him for years
until birth old,
died and birth will believe that Joe has
psychic powers and I called Joe up one
time.
I said,
why you doing this?
This guy has been through enough.
You know,
we've already expose it as a fraud,
as a fake,
you know,
why are you doing this to that guy?
And rather than answer the question,
he pretended
that he was his brother that had
answered the phone,
but I know Joe and I knew Joe and I knew
it was his brother doesn't sound
anything like him.
So isn't it possible that some people
like,
look,
some people like playing tennis.
Some people like fucking with people,
right?
He likes fucking with people that sport
probably.
Yeah.
He probably gets a hold of a mouse,
doesn't kill it,
so let's it crawl away a little bit.
Then swats it and brings it back and
that's it.
Survive.
I mean that's probably what he was
doing.
Well sometimes a mouse likes that,
right?
No,
I don't think the mouse over like I was
talking to my friend.
No,
I was talking to my friend tires.
Right.
So there's this thing of this enzyme
that cats have.
I can't think of what it talks to a
plasma enzyme.
It's a parasite.
Parasites.
Then that goes into some nice where they
think it's okay to have fun to play with
a cat or a more complicated than that,
but it actually turns their sexual
reward system sideways where the cat is
the.
When the cat urinates the smell of cat
urine,
gets them excited and actually makes the
mouse aroused and it removes all fear
of,
uh,
of the cat cat.
Yeah.
Because the only way that toxoplasmosis
gone d,
which is the parasite can reproduce,
is inside the cat's gut.
So the cat has to eat the mouse or the
rat in order for this parasite to
reproduce.
And then the reproduction.
The thing is it doesn't affect the cat's
behavior,
which is very strange,
but it does affect people.
It does affect people.
And it does affect rats and mice.
Yeah.
Do you think that's why we have cat
ladies?
Oh yeah.
You think it affects those crazy
bitches,
you think?
You said it doesn't affect,
it doesn't affect people,
but do you think it does affect?
It doesn't affect.
Cat's got.
Gotcha.
The cat's behavior seems to be the same,
exactly the same,
but it definitely affects people.
It makes people more impulsive.
There's a bunch of weird correlations.
There's a recent study that showed that
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurial
behavior is often connected with
toxoplasmosis infection.
Wow.
People are more risk.
They're more inclined to take risks and
take chances.
It's also,
there's a disproportionate number of
motorcycle victims,
uh,
of crashes that have toxoplasmosis
infection.
Really?
Yeah.
This came from Robert Sapolsky,
his work.
He's a professor at Stanford.
We had a chance to interview him.
Fascinating guy.
Yeah.
Well,
a lot of his,
uh,
his work he's done on toxoplasmosis.
You think there's other,
a lot of other things like that that we
don't realize that affect human
behavior?
There could very well be.
I mean,
there's a bunch of different parasites
that people get and you know,
there was another guy,
God,
what's his name?
Hortense out of University of Houston.
Peter Hotez dammit.
Anyway,
he's an infectious disease expert who
specializes in same television show that
I worked with you and he said that
people that live in jungle,
literally 100 percent percent of them,
100 percent are infected with parasites
while various parasites,
some documented,
some undocumented.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And many of them control behavior.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
There's some of them that are really
creepy,
like there's one,
there's an aquatic worm that talks at
grasshopper and drowning so that it can
give birth,
so it literally gets into the
grasshoppers brain rewires it's brain,
tells the grasshopper to jump into the
water so it can come out of its body and
exist in the water.
It's amazing when you think about that,
right?
How those things have developed to be
able to do exactly specifically what
they,
certain things need them to do.
So that's something else can benefit
from it.
Is that what his name is?
Because I wanted to get a benefit.
What?
Trying to find it out.
I couldn't cut down it that way.
I think it's Peter Hotez.
Ortez Shit.
Sorry.
University of Houston.
Um,
I can find it pretty sure.
Pretty sure anyway,
so yeah,
I mean your friend probably just like
fucking with people and you'd probably
feel like this guy's a dummy.
I'm just gonna.
Keep fucking with these dummies.
Have you ever do it?
Because I wanted to.
Oh,
I know you did that.
I thought I was doing the right thing
and I didn't realize that these people
are going to become my friends.
I'm eating with them every day.
They've got these lives,
you know,
and I care about people and at some
point I know that I'm going to have to
come out and it's going to be
devastating for them.
You know,
he did it for years,
got tenure at the university.
He's going to look like an idiot at the
end of this and that wasn't my purpose
of doing it much bigger picture.
Yes,
I get it,
but that is what he is.
No,
no,
I agree.
And that's what I'm saying.
There's a much bigger picture.
I would do the same thing again.
I would just protect myself emotionally,
I think more than I did then.
So you went to become friends with.
I would not become close friends with.
I wouldn't share a lot of my life with
them.
I wouldn't want to learn about their
life.
I'd want to keep it much more maybe than
you dragged it on for so long,
you know?
Maybe if you just did it over a couple
of days,
no way to do that.
I mean,
we would have days where we would do
nothing.
Like we literally sat in the lab and
nothing would happen for an entire.
That's fucking commitment,
man.
Do that shit over four years.
Well,
here's the thing,
right?
It's,
it's a bit misleading because it's 180
hours total and what that means is we'll
coming out on holidays were coming out
on weekends would coming out on that.
You're extending this project for a long
time and we weren't making money at it.
You know,
there was a podium that paid for our
food,
but that's about it.
Yeah.
You were just doing it for the
procedure.
I lost money because I had to take time
off work.
Yeah.
It's,
I think it's what you did as a good
thing.
Yeah.
Document because you show that even
scientists can be tricked if they're not
really following the scientific method
and that was the way to do it because
there were even some psychologist who
said,
look,
if you think you can infiltrate a
laboratory,
go ahead and do it.
So we were doing things in accordance
with what some of the psychological as a
psychologist we actually saying we
should do for sure.
Like that's the whole game.
The game is you're supposed to be.
They're supposed to try to find out if
you're tricking them.
So they should be assuming you're
tricking them.
Yep.
So they're not assuming you're tricking
them,
they're tricking themselves and that is
part of the problem with psychics.
Like I had a friend of mine went to a
psychic and they're like,
oh my God.
He knew all about my grandma.
I go,
don't you know about your grandma?
if this motherfucker really knows
psychic,
he really knows his psychic power.
They're going to tell you some shit you
don't know.
Telling you things about your life.
You already know I don't need anybody to
tell me about my life.
Now that's a good thing,
right?
That's all they're doing and there's
ways to get that info from you without
you realizing what I was saying this to
my friend,
he did not want to listen to me.
He wanted to believe so strong and he
definitely didn't want to believe they
got tricked.
This is part of the problem with
scammers.
Have you ever seen some of those
scammers,
those Nigerian scammers,
and get these poor,
lonely Melina to think that women are
waiting for them in Europe?
There was a terrible television show.
I mean terrible in that.
It was so sad.
This one guy flew to Europe twice to be
with this woman and every time he flew
there she had something come up and meet
him.
It was devastating.
She couldn't meet him and he.
He kept going back and his daughter was
saying,
I can't convince him that this is a
scam.
He really believes this woman's waiting
for him.
He's never heard this woman's voice.
She says she can't talk on the phone,
but she,
he,
she sends pictures and he really
believes strongly.
You know,
it's,
it's really sad.
I,
that's why I find like in like Penn,
Penn Jillette gave me one of the biggest
compliments that I've ever had actually
at one point,
um,
he had seen me work and his wife had
seen me work.
Emily had seen me work and emily came
and she said,
yeah,
Penn said that if we didn't know you
were not psychic from that demonstration
from watching a show,
you were the most convincing psychic
we've ever seen.
Well,
I said to,
yeah.
So the same thing to Duncan when you did
that performance for us on television.
I'm like,
that is the craziest shit if you weren't
so adamant that what you were doing was
a trick.
Right.
And Doug was like,
dude,
what if he's fucking with man?
He really is.
Dunkin tends to,
um,
you know,
he,
he has a thirst for the fantastic.
Yeah.
So for him,
which is nice that you can play off of
that,
that it's,
it's a good thing to have.
Uh,
yeah.
I,
um,
my,
my house,
it showed for that exact reason,
the show I'm doing in Rochester,
it's called telepathy and the first half
usually it's gonna be,
I don't actually have to hats,
but normally I do.
Normally it's a two hour show,
but I've had to cut it down to an hour
show and the first half was always me
coming out talking about telepathy.
What is telepathy?
What did Einstein,
he believed it was radio waves.
Marie Curie believed that it was,
telepathy was a real way that he even
wrote the foreword to a book called
telepathy.
So yeah,
yeah,
he believed it was a real thing.
He believed your mind give out radio
waves that other people actually picked
up a Sigmund Freud believed it was
related,
a dream state,
you know,
there was all these different third
theories.
I mean,
the word was coined in,
I think it was 18,
42 by uh,
Frederick Myers and he believes certain
things about telepathy.
So there was all these different things.
Um,
uh,
I start off a Conan doyle who wrote
Sherlock Holmes,
you know,
most rational character in literature.
He believed that with spirits all around
us,
it could pluck a thought out of one
person's mind and actually put it in
another.
So he believed all prognostication.
All these things have to do this,
had to do with spiritualism.
So there's all these people.
I mean the US government,
you know,
about Star Gate,
they gave $20,000,000 in the seventies
going on into the nineties to study and
find out if this stuff had any practical
military applications on these type of
things.
So remote viewing,
tell it.
Yeah,
well that's where remote viewing came
out.
The other thing,
stargate not cured me of that television
show did try to do that.
You did that.
I think you actually did that with the,
with Dj growthy on there as well,
so.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think he was part of that,
but of that Dj,
me and Dj both did better.
Just faking it then.
That's great.
We just made a bunch of shit up and drew
some stick figures.
That's how that can be the tower.
This is the tower is about.
Actually it was a man,
but it looks like a tower.
Right?
There was the one guy that's famous for
remote viewing.
I interviewed him as well.
What is his name?
Yeah,
you say his name.
I'll know it.
I'm not bell all the time.
They'll be on there for hours and hours
and hours and met him and I was like,
is this guy fucking with me?
Yeah.
And he was explaining how he worked for
the US government,
how they found Osama bin Ladin fucking
bonkers somewhere else that,
that doesn't work.
Fun Guy.
Yeah.
Was telling me about his hot Russian
girlfriend.
I was like,
all right,
tell me more about that.
Let's go that direction.
Can I remote viewer?
I think you put it in my head right now.
Can I see which.
Oh,
she's in the bathtub to be more having a
demon ejaculation.
And
so anyway,
since that time I've,
I've gone after many different things.
Um,
Peter Popoff,
the evangelist said he was getting the
word of God.
Randy came to Houston in 1986.
The earpiece in?
Yeah,
I found the earpiece.
Oh,
you found that it was me.
Yeah.
So Randy was writing an article,
I think it was Hustler magazine.
It was one of those magazines on
evangelists,
evangelists.
It was a good place to hide something.
It was one of the things.
It may not have been hustled,
so I don't want you to quote me on that.
That house did a lot of those and that's
what I'm saying.
I didn't Penthouse,
but I don't think it plays a lot.
I think it was hustling,
but I could be wrong is one of the ones
that people actually read because the
girls never take their panties off.
So you get bored with just looking at
now though it didn't.
They go back to.
Well they don't know they were.
They went to looking after.
They did not do it at all.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Show amazing willpower.
Sorry.
They went to the key needs or underwear.
They stopped taking their clothes off.
But then sales inexplicably tank.
It's so strange.
Those articles,
they did have good articles in playboy,
had interviews.
They had a lot of groundbreaking on
through the years.
Buddy of mine had a book of all the
different playboy interviews.
Over the years,
and I was like,
well,
I have some good stuff.
Yeah,
so randy.
Randy for Hustler.
Yeah.
Writing for us though on evangelist.
He said,
Hey,
do you want to come see this evangelists
with me?
I'm like,
yeah,
sure,
I'll come.
So went there and it was about 10,000
people.
It's downtown,
Big Auditorium,
Houston,
huge auditorium.
You know,
all these people sitting around and a
pop off comes out on stage.
He starts saying he's getting the word
of God.
He's telling people their names,
information,
who their doctors are,
what their ailments are,
and he's.
He starts healing.
People have cancer.
He starts healing people of blindness.
People walking again,
and it was really,
really emotionally for me.
I tears in my eyes,
but I knew that was all bullshit,
but I had to news bullshit and crying.
It can you get this whole fucking life.
Like when you see a little kid crying
and running down the aisle,
you know,
you,
you want to get angry,
but at the same time it's like,
it's just so emotional.
It's just the.
You get caught up in this whole thing.
It's just new,
so he asked for people to collect money.
He's just asking random people,
come up,
grab a bucket,
go collect money.
I got down there.
I remember I was like the 15th bucket.
I got my bucket.
I walk around,
I get checks.
I got probably about,
I don't know how much.
10 grand,
20 grand.
I don't know.
You know what I've got?
I mean money.
First of all,
getting money.
Then you've got to.
I'm think I'm done.
He said,
nope.
Yeah,
okay.
Once you got to go back out and collect
checks and now we're going out getting
checks in the bucket and then it's like
go out,
get sealed offerings and people are
dropping envelopes in there with like
watches,
rings and stuff like that.
As I come back,
I hand the bucket up to pop off and I
look up and I noticed that he's got a
piece of plastic in his ear.
I go back to randy and I say,
Randy,
I said,
look,
either this man of God,
God doesn't like him enough to heal him
and he's got a hearing aid or something
else is going on.
I don't know what,
but something else is going on and I
think that's how he's getting
information.
And Randy was like,
no,
he's using mnemonics.
Mnemonics that basically memory systems.
All right.
I,
you,
I have to use a lot of mnemonics to
memorize things because otherwise I have
major issues and I know a lot about
mnemonics.
You either memorize a lot of bad things
about a few things.
Oh you memorize a few things about a lot
of things,
but you don't memorize a lot of things
about a lot of things.
And he was memorizing a lot of things
If that was the case,
I said,
I don't think so.
So they went out to the next pet,
pop off a congregation thing when she
was in San Francisco,
got a friend of ours from a Alec,
Jason,
I think his name is,
uh,
from a WHO's an electronics engineer and
that was everything about electronics.
And he brought this little scanner and
dressed up as a security guard hanging
out in the back.
And he was scared to death he was going
to get called.
Nobody questioned him.
He's there in a security outfit and he
scans all the frequencies ahead of time
and he blocks out every one of those
frequencies that are known frequencies.
The moment pop off hits the stage,
a brand new frequency pops up and turns
out,
I think it was a 37 point.
I can tell you in just a second here.
It was A.
Yeah.
Wait,
was that the frequency that he was on
was?
Yep.
I thought it was right.
Yeah.
30 nine point seven megahertz.
That's what God broadcasts on and it
sounds an awful lot like Peter popoff
wife.
So what we did was we taped all this and
went to the Johnny Carson show.
This is how long ago that was.
Now on this night show with Johnny
Carson.
Randy takes it on the tonight show and
keep in mind that I'm pop off with tape
every single one of his shows and sort
of edit it real time as well.
You put them on television.
Yeah,
it will put them all on television.
This is how we make tons of.
I mean they were.
They had a,
a monthly budget.
I think it was like $550,000 every
single month,
you know,
that,
that was a working budget,
that that's not the money.
They will actually make it.
So God knows how much.
So that's how much they were spending so
much they were spending.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So God,
what a dirty business.
Yeah.
It's so dirty.
It's so dirty to just lie to people like
that.
I,
if I would make a great evangelists if I
wasn't ethical,
there are times like,
Oh God,
you know,
but I just couldn't do it.
I couldn't do it.
So on the tonight show they play,
they play the footage that they have
from his TV show.
They play all that and then they.
Oh,
and this was the one time that Johnny
always wanted to know everything that
was going to happen.
Like she didn't want any surprises,
but his staff said,
no,
you,
you want to be surprised by this,
trust this.
So sure enough they play that footage
and then they play the footage with pop
offs wife and she's saying things like
pd.
The first thing she says,
PD,
nod your head if you can hear me,
because if you don't,
we're going to have trouble tonight.
He nods his head as he's talking,
you know,
doing this whole event gelical thing.
Um,
and uh,
then she starts saying,
oh,
there's a live one up in the back.
She's got cancer in her breast and make
her run up and down the island,
shake those breaths,
you know,
it's just always like re.
And there's a lot of nasty stuff.
Some of that stuff we couldn't play on
this night show,
but we showed enough.
And so just a disdain the marketing of
these people.
She actually had breast cancer and she's
telling that these people do these real
elements that all these people,
well,
almost real elements.
I'll get to that in a second because we
sent some stitches in and uh,
so yeah,
just nasty,
nasty stuff.
But anyway,
the stuff we showed him the tonight
show,
Johnny sits there and he never,
he didn't like to edit it shows either,
but he had to edit this because a moment
that came on Johnny's like,
Oh shit.
And you couldn't say shit on TV back
then.
And so we had to edit that out at that
point and he says like,
do they know about this?
And like,
nope,
they do now.
And at first pop off,
try to say that we,
we,
uh,
we hired actors to be his wife.
And then when it was obvious that we
didn't,
he then came out and says,
I thought everybody knew that I use that
to enhance the word of God.
And it took a long time for him to go
onto that.
Here's,
here's the crappy thing about this,
right when I was there,
he's doing stuff like telling people to
throw their medications up on stage.
You don't need them.
God's going to take care of,
you know,
imagine somebody throws up some
digitalis pills or something they
really,
truly need and think God's going to heal
them.
So people do die from these things.
And he was using a lot of other tricks.
I,
Oh,
I'm part of the way he was getting the
information was this,
right?
So people fill out prayer cards ahead of
time and they put them in these boxes in
the back of the room when nobody's
really paying attention,
the boxes get switched out.
So all those prayer cards with all this
information goes backstage.
So the wife and she's able to send that
information to him.
Another thing,
she would come out on stage,
she would come out,
people come to these things for hours
and hours ahead of time,
like literally and they leave the
hospital on carts and everything else
and she would walk and she said,
hi,
I'm Mrs Popoff go.
I hope my husband gets to you tonight.
You know,
where are you from?
Oh,
that's nice.
Well,
what's wrong with you?
Oh I'm so well.
I'll pray for you.
And she gets all this information again.
She'd go back.
She had a big tape recorder in her purse
and she would write that information
down.
Another one was what I call like the
Kathryn Kuhlman trick and Catherine
Coleman was an evangelist way,
way back who had all these great,
great little like scam trick things.
And what they do is they wait for
somebody to come walk in with a cane and
then they can walk but not well,
and they're using a cane.
They walk up to them and say,
you know what?
Wouldn't you be much more comfortable in
a wheelchair and we can put you up right
up front.
You'll be right next to the reverend.
Who's going to say no to that?
So they get pushed up in the wheelchair.
And as I pushed them along,
they said,
well,
you're from WHO's your doctor?
You know what's wrong with getting all
this information?
Go back out,
write the information down and giving
Mrs Popoff.
So the wheelchair sitting there,
reverent comes out.
At some point he can look at that
person.
He didn't,
he said so name.
And he says,
we've never talked before.
We've never met before,
have we?
Because they haven't.
It was the usher that was pushing him
down to gut that info.
He says,
you know,
God says you can be healed.
Now.
God said,
I'm getting from God that you can't
walk.
Is that right?
And the guy sitting there,
he's thinking,
this is a man of God,
right?
So I'm not contradicting him.
And he must mean never be at a walk
properly again.
That's what he's saying.
He's saying that my doctor says I can
never walk properly again.
So he doesn't contradict him.
He says,
I say you can.
God says you can stand up.
The man stands up.
Well,
that's your first miracle because
everybody else,
their perception is this,
guys in that wheelchair cannot walk.
He said,
take a few steps that it takes a few
steps.
You got that beat,
it's war,
right?
So now you've got the emotion going even
more.
Because here's a man that couldn't even
walk.
He stood and now he walked,
pop off,
then goes and gets in the wheelchair and
sits in it.
He says,
walk to the back of the wheelchair and
the guy hobbles to the back of the
wheelchair.
He says,
push me.
And the guy pushes him.
Real miracle,
right?
But think about it.
That will chair is now acting like a
fricken walker.
And then the great climax of the whole
piece of this trick is he takes the
wheelchair,
puts it back where it is,
and he says to him,
now that's your wheelchair,
meaning Joe,
like if you got up right now,
walked across the room and said,
Yo,
that's your chair.
You'd say,
yes,
will it actually is your jail.
You own it.
But I mean in normal circumstances I say
you were in my studio.
You'd go,
yes,
doesn't mean that your chair,
it just means it's where you're sitting
in that moment.
So the permits and sits down and you've
seen this whole miracle.
So he's got all these tricks like that.
The old trick of one leg is longer than
the other and you make them both the
same size.
Also,
people get caught up in the moment and
they're on television.
They want it to be real.
And the good,
I think an interesting.
That's a lot of things,
but I don't think so.
In this case,
I think this is more of a religious
thing that people truly believe.
And when you have.
It's like when I was talking tongues,
when I was yelling,
you know,
I've got all this stuff,
me and I got all this adrenaline flowing
through my body.
When you get caught up in it,
it's like when I was watching it,
you know,
I'm getting caught up.
I'm having all this reaction in my body
despite the fact I know it's all
bullshit.
I'm still having this,
this entire reaction,
you know,
it's,
mediums to me.
The worst scum out there right now are
the mediums and why do I say that?
Because they're taking advantage of a
person in a vulnerable moment in their
life and they're doing it for that long
game.
They're also doing it for money and a
lot of people will say,
well,
then making them feel good.
You know what?
I can give crack to a junkie.
It doesn't mean it's good for him,
right?
The grieving process is a natural part
of the state that you have to go through
to stay with the living.
We had a very good friend whose son died
of cancer,
10 years old,
died of cancer.
She's understanding he has this huge
gaping hole,
right,
is huge,
gaping hole,
which she's just feeling sad.
She's upset,
she needs to fill it with something.
Normally you turn to your family for
those things,
but she met.
She met a medium who convinced the she
could talk to her dead son,
so she stopped talking to her two living
daughters.
She stopped talking to her husband,
she started talking to the meat,
even talking to her dead son,
almost ended up with a divorce,
almost lost her entire life as a result,
and this happens all the time and it is
so,
so sad and dirty,
very dirty people on long island medium
you ever watched.
So Theresa Caputo
and the worst part is the networks that
edit the stuff to make it look even
better.
If they don't give a fuck,
they're just trying to make money and
just try to make money.
That's all they don't care about.
Somehow or another feel like they're not
a part of the scam.
I mean,
they're literally committing fraud.
They aren't there.
No,
I agree.
They're perpetrating the fraud.
Well,
the network is not involved with what it
is,
is a production company.
The production company is bringing it to
the network,
but the network should know the process
and knows what's going on.
They know it's bullshit,
but it's like,
you know what?
I was going to get ratings.
It's going to do this.
Let's promote it,
let's push it.
You know,
they show up on set on Psi Phi and the
network.
They didn't want me just debunking
everything.
No,
and I had to tell them,
I said,
the problem is everything's bullshit.
Yeah.
It's not that I'm trying to debunk
everything.
We're just really looking at it.
Yeah,
everything's bullshit.
Well,
it's why in my show I started to go on
this a little bit ago that showed
telepathy where I talk about telepathy
and what it is and everything else,
but as I'm doing it,
I'm performing and there's a part in
that show where I feel really,
really dirty and I feel really,
really bad,
but I feel like I have to do it.
And I actually talked to some people's
dead relatives in that show and it's
like the most despicable,
horrible thing and it makes me want to
cry every time I do it,
but it's because in the second half of
the show I go,
what is telepathy?
Well,
I think I know what it is.
I think it's a,
a,
a subset of magic.
I think it's a form of entertainment and
a very cruel form of entertainment.
I know I played with emotions if any of
you here this,
but how else can I convince you on an
emotional level?
And on a logical level that is bullshit.
Because here's the thing,
right?
It's like your friend.
They've had this one experience that's
an emotional experience meeting the
psychic and the psychic telling them,
if you tell them,
hey,
well I got this friend band check,
they could do that same thing for you.
He's going,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
but this is,
you know,
or if I do it,
say Bennett checks are real soft,
they train us to meet up and then I do
it.
And he goes,
wow,
that God's real.
Then now you say it's bullshit,
now they'll think a little bit and go,
well,
you know what?
I had that same emotional experience.
I had that same feeling.
Maybe maybe I'll look at it.
My job,
I feel he's never to break down a
person's belief systems,
you know,
you can believe whatever you want,
that's fine.
So long as you're not hurting anybody
else,
I'm Kinda sorta okay with it.
But the big thing is the problem that I
have is with the people that have taken
advantage of those people's beliefs,
cause it's always wolves in sheep's
clothing.
They're taking advantage of people go
down these side streets and there's
these houses,
there's little houses that are sided
houses where people live in them and
some of them do,
like you look at those houses,
they're like fricking like beautiful.
And they look like these people must be
making money like huge money somehow
unless they're laundering money or
something on the side as well.
I mean there's enough people that
believe in.
Unfortunately they're good at it.
They just hustle people and yeah,
it's a weird legal scam.
I mean to,
in order to like the government's
constantly shutting down cults and all
sorts of things that are not legit that
they find to be dangerous,
but they somehow or another allow
people,
like some of them had got arrested
recently for scamming someone out of
hundreds of thousands of dollars and it
was the same sort of a thing.
She was a psychic and she was saying
that she needed all this money for.
Right,
for some fucking Mino about where I'll
frames,
right?
No.
So he was like,
he,
I think he like,
he was like a multi millions and
millions of dollars and there was a long
scan that went on for a long time.
I think it was a,
what was it?
I think I ever down there somewhere,
I don't know where.
But anyway,
round frames,
he was,
uh,
he,
he basically grew trees and replanted
trees and old trees and everything he
said made millions and millions off
this.
So there was this lady,
uh,
he got scammed for five point $5,000,000
over the course of a long period of
time,
but it all started out with the,
he met this lady and a psychic
bookstore,
a,
she gave him a bit of a reading and
through the reading she found out that
his dad wasn't well and she said that
she had taken care of her dad through
hospice and everything,
but she had actually done it herself.
She ended up moving in with him.
She ended up getting him because she was
doing readings,
convinced him he,
she was psychic.
She ended up getting him buying him like
at $950,000 home,
uh,
which will all these investments.
She ended up taking over all of his
finances.
She moved in with him romantically.
No,
no,
this is the weird part,
right.
So she didn't,
she was rude in as the caretaker for
the,
for the father.
Um,
but in the process of all this,
she's getting,
she's now taking over his finances.
She's convinced that they're going
bankrupt.
They got to pay the taxes.
That tax money is getting funneled
through her,
gets deeper than this.
One day he's at the bus station.
There's this blonde hair,
beautiful girl with an English accent
that comes on over and she starts giving
him a reading and he ends up marrying or
thinks he actually marries us.
Go at some point.
Turns out this goal is the daughter of
the other woman.
Her name is portia.
And what did they call their kid?
They called their kid a Giorgio Armani.
Now.
Now,
now here's the thing,
right?
They had a kid together,
but he thought he had a kid with her.
It turns out the kid was a cousin's baby
that she brought in the House and acted
like she had the baby.
Wait a minute.
No,
no.
You can look this all up online.
It's all online.
I like being.
Well,
she used the baby bump thing,
you know,
and then she acted like she had a second
kid,
but she lost that child and everything
else.
And the only way they got caught is
because the boyfriend of,
I think the mother,
I think it was.
We're now in the same day and bought
these these cars for like a million but
box almost close to that,
you know,
that he just went out and spent the
money.
So the US government started coming,
come in and say,
wait,
what's going on here?
How is this going down?
And it all came to light up,
but as.
Yeah,
yeah,
Ralph rains,
so I want to believe Shit,
you know,
they just want to believe and it's a
strange thing.
I wonder what that is.
Do you think that that's some sort of.
There's some sort of an evolutionary
aspect to thought were like to find
things that are hidden or secrets is a
part of our thirst for innovation or a
thirst to.
To invent things or to.
To figure out problems more to,
to,
to not be deceived.
I think it's part of survival,
right?
You're always looking for that next
evolution of what,
what's gonna work and if we could read
minds that would help us in our lives,
right?
It would say it was a lot of pain.
If I know that she's really cheating on
me or she's lying to me or he's lying to
me or,
but it's not just a psychic energy
that's like ghosts and all the other
stuff too.
It all seems connected,
but it,
it is that almost evolutionary to say I
think we always strive to better
ourselves and to get that kind of
knowledge and if there's a possibility,
there's an afterlife.
Wow,
what does that really mean for me as a
human being and sort of the evolutionary
scale now I'm just thinking about things
that I do in a very different manner.
Right?
It's also like this weird desire that
people have to know things that are
hidden.
Those.
One of the reasons why that's the
conspiracies.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
that is part of survival.
It's like,
Hey,
I wonder what's behind that cave right
there.
Oh,
I wonder what's over the top of that
mountain.
Are there any animals over there that I
can hunt in that field whatsoever there?
Where's a better place to fish right
now?
Where's the better place to hunt?
And it's all about survival I think.
I think really on some level it's a
really screwed up thing that's in our
head pattern that helps us sort of
survived.
You know,
you talk about people wanting to believe
things.
You know,
there was a guy,
there was a Russian psychic.
He Frankel,
I think his name was.
Now imagine this Joe.
So you're a conductor on a train,
right?
And you're going down some tracks with a
train and you see a guy in a white suit
just looking at the side,
looking down towards you,
coming down the tracks,
puts down a briefcase,
steps right in front of the train,
stares at the train,
puts his hand up in sort of a stop
motion,
but you can't stop car.
Hit Him and knock him.
You killed the guy.
He's in a million pieces of whatever
happened to him and actual real guy.
They opened up the briefcase and inside
there's a letter says,
I stopped a bicycle.
I stopped the car,
I stopped a street car,
and now I'm going to do the ultimate
thing.
I'm going to stop a train.
This was a psychic who believed he had
powers.
Now my thinking on this,
I'm going,
first of all,
Yay.
Probably stepped in front of a bicycle
and of course it stopped.
The president put the brakes on,
you know,
he stood in front of her car and it also
stopped,
of course,
and the street car.
I just got lucky with the train was a
huge mistake.
They say it can't stop in time,
but this guy really truly believe he had
these abilities and then I get really,
really cynical and I started thinking
because I think about my ex wife and
stuff and crazy stuff and I go,
I go,
yeah,
maybe had an ex wife,
maybe not an ex wife,
but a wife who said to him,
Hey,
you know,
frankly,
I bet you can stop a bicycle,
hire some guy next door to take a bike,
you know,
and stuff like that.
I bet you can stop a car.
Same Guy in the car,
you know,
stop slams on the brake.
You know,
he happens also to be the street car
driver as well,
you know,
so he stops and everything else.
She says,
you know what?
You really have these powers and you
should step in front of a train and try
to stop.
So,
but that's just me being cynical.
So.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a good way to think,
especially when you've pulled off what
you've pulled off and seen what you've
seen.
Yeah.
You should have a show where you bust
these mediums.
We have a show right now.
Um,
but it's not really.
Here's the intro.
It's like you said,
right?
Networks don't want a debunking show.
Yeah.
Because that kills all their other show.
We had a show years ago where we came
out and said it was all an illusion,
but they called it magical miracle.
And Gallo is on that show and they had
taped blowing out of the water.
Basically gallows saying stuff that he
denied.
He said later on,
but they had the tape of it and they
could have shown that,
but they wanted to keep that thing of
magic or miracle.
And that was geller a fraud.
Did girl trick you gotta be careful how
you say this because he loves to sue
people.
Oh,
okay.
But he started to sell people right now
that he's the world's greatest magician,
but he's got to be careful with that
because he sued people who said that he
was a magician and everything else,
it is my opinion from everything that
I've seen and the Times that I've
watched him,
that he is cheating and he is using
tricks.
And I know that I know for a fact he
uses some of my methods now as well.
I also know when I was working on the
show phenomenon the first time I told
this story ever,
um,
so on,
I worked on a TV show for now
phenomenon.
It was finding the next year he,
Gallo Criss Angel was on that show as
well.
And they were the judges on the show and
I'm geller calls me out of the blue,
which was really unexpected because I've
always been on the other side of the
fence of gala,
you know,
with Randy and the skeptical movement in
that.
And um,
he calls me up and he says,
hey,
how you doing?
I said,
I'm doing good.
He says,
well,
you know,
you're known as the guy that creates a
stuff,
you know,
every mentalist working today is getting
a couple of your effects that you've
created.
Um,
and he says,
you know,
I only have like four or five powers
that I've had through the years and if
anybody could come up with a new psychic
ability for me,
it would be you.
And I went,
wow.
How ballsy is that?
Right?
He's calling sort of like one of his
hoping that you're hoping.
No,
he's hoping I can create a new trick for
him that he can tell the world is
psychic.
Right.
But he's also must be hoping that you're
not going to expose them.
Well,
this is the great thing,
right?
Like even right now when I'm saying
this,
this is when you hang up,
you know,
I go,
why would he do that?
And I thought,
well it was just a phone call between me
and him.
He knows I wasn't expecting it.
So I'm not recording it.
It's my word against his word.
And he can say that I misunderstood that
maybe he wanted me to need to come up
with an idea of something for him to use
his psychic power.
So there's many ways you could spin it.
When we worked with Chris Angel,
Chris,
uh,
on one of his episodes had geller on
there and Chris put a spoon on the table
and he said,
you know,
can you,
can you bend that and your.
He said,
no.
well,
why not?
He said,
well,
my abilities aren't Oregon writing.
So.
So if you bent at right now,
it would be a trick.
Right?
And I can't bend it right now.
He says,
well,
if you did bend it,
it would be a trick.
Right?
And Gallo says,
well,
yeah,
if I bent it right now,
it would be a trick.
And Christmas I got him.
I got him,
you know,
and when he walked away,
I said,
you don't have him.
And he said,
well,
what do you mean?
He just said it was a trick.
I said,
no,
he never said it was a trick.
He said if he had to do it in that
moment,
it would be a trick because it's psychic
abilities weren't working.
He never says he knows how to do it as a
trick.
He just said it would have to be a
Sure enough,
I walked up together later on,
he says,
you know,
I didn't say that.
I use tricks.
Right?
I go,
yeah,
I know,
you know,
he's,
he's collaborative,
like very,
very clever and very,
very slick.
So,
and I,
you know,
I think he's harmed science and took it
back and it was one of these things I
think why we had to do what we had to do
at the time because science was going in
this very weird pseudo science
direction.
I mean,
that was back in the days when you had,
um,
old pyramids that would basically put a
razorblade supposedly,
and it would show up.
And so you got all the pyramids of power
and you had.
Yeah,
I remember that stuff.
That stuff was put things into pyramids
that sharpened them.
Yeah.
I didn't,
didn't work,
but it was just,
it's all pseudoscience,
but it was all this,
you know,
people wearing a tinfoil hats and just
written into the whole thing.
Went on and on and on and on.
It was a list of just the whole litany
of whatever happened to pop off,
pop off.
I'm just disappeared.
Oh,
he's back on every night now you can
find him on every night.
Now the differences this.
Right.
So he was one of the first ones to send
out and you've probably seen them.
He would send out these letters that
look like there were handwritten.
It's obvious now we look at it,
we know it's
not handwritten,
you know,
that the printed.
But back then people weren't aware of
that and it looks like it's handwritten
and personal to you.
And I would get,
because I just signed up when I was at
were there that day.
I would get an outline of a foot,
wear this in your shoe and uh,
you know,
wrap it up with $20,
$50,
$100,
whatever you put in,
you'll get tenfold back.
Hey,
you know,
you get this little piece of water and
it came from Bethlehem and you know
where that around your neck and then
wrap it up with money and send that,
send that back.
So he was making most of his money,
not at the,
the events he was making it on the
mailings.
That's where they will making really
making all their money.
Took a few years for him to disappear,
like about three,
four years to him disappear.
And after this night show.
Yeah.
And then he came back,
but the differences,
now he's not using any of those tricks.
It's more of a thing that he's on the
air and he's going,
somebody out there has a headache right
now and I'm going to help kill you.
Have your migraines.
You don't have to if you're just on
television.
Yeah.
You don't have to do anything.
Right?
You just say that point.
There was a heart attack right now.
Jesus gonna.
Stop at Jay's a stump.
That heart attack.
That's right guys.
Guys on the couch.
Whoa.
Jesus.
He's having heartburn and it goes away.
It's like,
oh my Gosh,
God just failed me.
I'm going to send them money.
Liter Pepsi.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So,
so that's,
that's what he's doing now,
which is um,
I don't know,
I just,
I,
I don't think any of these we should be
tax exempt or anything like that.
So that's what's terrifying.
It's terrifying.
Is that they're tax exempt and obviously
a fraud.
Like how has the government so lax in
that?
I don't know.
I don't know if it's even this whole
thing of like I'm not for profit
organizations,
right?
I mean,
you know,
they,
most of them are just fraud.
They're fakes as far as I think you
should have to prove that a certain
percentage is actually going to the
cause,
the problem with five percent whatever.
And you can only have x amount of
employees.
The rest of the volunteers and the
employees can get paid a lot of money to
nonprofit will be certain amount of
poise.
Maybe the president this and this.
They can only make x amount of dollars
in a nonprofit or organization.
They can't make more than that.
Or You lose your nonprofit status
because you're self sufficient at that
point.
Yeah,
no,
I,
I agree with you totally.
It's very disturbing to me that,
I mean,
look,
scientology sued and won and they became
nonprofit.
I mean they are.
Or rather they became tax exempt because
they're,
what?
They had so much money.
They had a religion.
Every member's money was pulled to be
able to sue anybody to the point to
where you couldn't win.
Right.
Well,
they were suing so many people that the
irs just gave it.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's really fascinating.
It's fascinating how they did that.
They actually fought the irs and one.
Right,
but they got that money from the people
that they're the congregation.
It's an incredible story really.
It,
it's just,
it's incredible that it's so obvious.
I mean,
when you got.
I mean there's,
there's religions,
right?
That we don't know the origin of.
I mean we really don't know who was the
original writer of this scroll is that
they're fine in Qumran we don't know who
wrote is too long ago.
Right.
But with l Ron Hubbard,
they got video of,
you know,
they know the guy in the video,
the guy saying,
hey,
if you want to make a lot of money,
start a religion,
not a religion.
And he did.
And and yeah,
when he had the captain's outfit on with
ribbons,
he gave himself and metals like,
what the fuck?
Well,
you know,
that's,
that's the front with this stuff is so
dangerous.
It's just so,
so dangerous in the wrong hands.
You recognize that it's dangerous
because you understand how easy people
are to be manipulated,
right?
Because you've been studying this your
whole life and you and you,
you know,
in a form of it,
you do a show.
What I really genuinely appreciate is
the way you and the way penn really go
out of their way to say that this is a
trick.
This is bullshit.
We're bullshitting you.
I'm not showing you spooky power.
I got in a lot of trouble for that in my
early days of performing bind reading a
mentalism.
The moment that I came out and I would
say to p because to me,
I think when you come out and you tell
people it's not real and you can still
do it and they want to tell you that has
to be real.
That means something.
Right.
That's.
That's impressive to me.
I think that's really impressive.
There are a lot of performers who are
not good performance.
They started out not as good performance
and they need the people to believe in
them in order to get away with a
trickery and they never lose that.
They always want people to believe.
It's a tricky one.
So when I started coming out and I
started saying,
hey,
it's magic.
It's verbal,
it's nonverbal communication.
It's all this stuff mixed together to
create a show.
I'm not a psychic.
There is absolutely nothing psychic
about what I do.
There were quite a few mentalist and the
mentalism field back then.
There wasn't as many as there are now,
who were upset with me dunked and said,
if you are a psychic man,
the best way to hide it,
to say you're not a psychic,
right?
Yeah,
no,
that wouldn't be true,
except that's not the case.
So what's up with the nails?
I don't know because we're two hours in
here.
Tell me what's up with these nails a
nail.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright,
so this is what I want you to do.
I just,
you're going to have to describe what's
happening.
Okay.
So this is one of the very first things
I started doing.
Joe,
is this like the nail Polish and nail
and I want you to watch what happens.
Okay?
I'm watching what happens.
Oh my God,
you're bending it.
This is incredible.
Your Business,
you can see the nail is actually slowly,
slowly bending.
Outrageous.
I like it.
You're shaking your hand to showing your
powers and the thing about that,
take a look at.
It's not a trick nail.
It's nothing like that.
I mean everything I use from silverware
to forks to anything that I do is
actually just slowly do that.
Yeah,
no,
but I was at the Va,
I was at the very end,
right?
They're like,
oh,
I can't,
I can't do that.
So here,
hold on another one maybe.
Yeah,
I'm going to say let's keep got some
forks.
Yeah,
I got some forks.
So I want you,
I want you to point to a fork.
Anyone?
Um,
how about this one?
You want it or do you want me to have
that one?
I'll take that one.
You'll take it.
All right.
So.
So you've heard of people,
we've talked about people actually
bending silverware,
but that one you can't.
Yeah,
that's the one I want.
I'm going to use it.
Give me that fucking for the time.
This I know what you doing.
Give me that fork a fork that's taken
bullshit for.
No,
you can have that fork.
John,
let's take you a fork.
Joe.
Try and get this Florida watching.
Um,
yeah.
This was your four incredible.
Trying to get this from the far end.
What kind of techniques are you using,
sir?
Tell me then I'll trick forks.
Well,
we're going to eat with these.
Those are,
those are actually 100 percent genuine
forks.
Um,
but you can't tell me how you're doing
it.
It's sleight of hand.
That's as much as I can tell you.
Okay,
let me do it.
Do it again so I could watch one more
time.
You want to watch one more time?
Okay.
I was hoping have like a bullshit fake
fork.
Not legit.
If I was sitting with you,
I'll show you.
It's actually no,
it's easier if I'm sitting with you.
So let's do a here.
People can tell.
Yep.
So what's this one?
Ready?
Here we go.
Okay.
So I'm going to shake it like that.
Right?
You know what?
Let's do it this way.
Can you wait?
Can I move this?
Yeah.
So hope both hands out like this and I'm
just going to.
I'm going to hold it right there.
I want you to hold that in and hold that
in for me.
I'm gonna.
Have to make it what you want to do.
Hold this end as well with that.
And I'm going to hold it right in the
center.
Right there.
Okay.
You're rubbing it.
Watch.
Oh,
you heating it up.
Wait,
wait.
Don't,
don't,
don't force it.
Don't force it.
Just hold it.
Can you feel that?
Yeah.
Because it's a different kind of metal.
No,
it's not.
Yeah.
You're,
you're using some sort of fake ass metal
and now it's hard again,
right,
because you're heating it up,
right?
Is that what it is?
What?
I'm going to actually get this one to
break him,
but I'm better now.
Chill.
Wow.
Right?
Because it's some bullshit ass metal.
I promise you it's not.
I have dvds out that teach musicians how
to do this.
Of course you got to be a magician.
No where to get it and it uses any fork
anywhere.
Anytime.
Promise you.
But I got Monday.
Ben.
No bending it
this way.
If they were made out a special metal,
I would never let you keep them because
it would be too expensive,
but this one's gonna twist all the way
around and that.
That one's not made a special metal.
It's regular metal hold.
I got to concentrate.
You do use it for real.
What kind of wizardry is that,
sir?
He spun this around and turn it into a
not.
The thing is he's not going to tell you
how he does it.
That's the real problem.
No,
you tell me that it's bullshit,
but you won't tell me how you're doing
this bullshit.
It's very unfortunate that there's
different techniques.
That's the thing,
right?
I mean,
and I really hope you can come see a
show.
Sometimes I do things like one person,
another person feels it.
I tell people to like,
name a number,
you know,
any number at all.
Go ahead.
13.
Okay.
And that would be a common number for
lot of people to choose.
Sure.
You know,
there are specific words,
if I said to you,
think of a number,
a name,
anywhere it was seven letters or less.
Go ahead.
Okay,
go ahead.
Con.
Of course,
most people wouldn't.
Most people that are common words.
No,
that's not a common word.
I had no most people to choose on love
or have something like that know along
those lines.
Uh,
you know,
a dog or cat,
a really common ones.
Um,
but,
but here's,
here's the interesting thing.
Okay.
So inside this wallet,
did you give up on the word because I
have chosen or there was no,
no,
yet inside this wallet I put it in car.
I was driving,
I was driving earlier on and someone cut
you off and you know what doodling,
doodling is when you kind of scribbled
without even looking.
And as you notice inside the hair,
you open it up.
Tell me what's on there.
So I didn't want to touch it.
What does it say?
It's hard to read.
Yeah,
it's my handwriting.
And doodling.
This is a 13 and count.
It does
shit.
Well,
it's such bad handwriting that I got to
think that you wrote that underneath the
table.
It's definitely a 13.
Right?
And,
and yeah.
Yeah.
Wrote it onto the table while we're
doing this.
What did end up inside the wallet?
Because he just shoved it in there.
Oh,
let's try this.
What's that one?
All right.
We'll try this.
I can't promise I'm going to be able to
do.
Okay.
You know what?
I got both of you in here.
Let's do this.
What are we going to do?
Right?
He's got a bunch of cards on him and
second deck of cards,
right?
That is great.
We have 13 and current written on the
piece of paper.
I should have washed your hands closer.
I'm a fan of cards out job.
Okay.
I'm not picking it now.
I'm not going to actually have to pick
one up.
I am in sort of.
I'm going to find it.
I'm not going to fanning because I'm not
a magician.
I'm going to show you the card payment.
You're not a magician.
I'm a mentalist.
What?
I'm going to find the cards.
I want you to think of any card,
any card.
I say you get one.
Okay.
You see it?
Yes.
Did you get a red card?
Excuse me?
You get a red card?
Yes.
Good.
So she got a red card and we do.
Same with you across the table.
I want you to think of any call to get a
black card.
Okay.
Do you get one?
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to ask one question because I
have to ask questions sometimes.
Try to figure out exactly what it is
you're thinking.
Okay.
Did either one of you choose a high
card?
Yes.
No.
Okay.
Hi.
Cards are hard for me to get,
but I will try.
All right.
Look at me.
Don't,
don't,
don't.
She got a red card.
I'm going to say your card is probably
hearts.
Your card over there,
Jamie.
It's black.
Probably.
Spades.
Nailed it
for two spades.
Yes.
Hearts Klinghardt's.
Yeah.
Well,
let me see.
That deck of cards.
We only had three choices.
Yeah.
I had a queen of spades and eight of
spades.
The two of spades and
I switched from the queen of spades.
Before you asked that question.
Higher low.
I went low.
Low.
Went low.
Yeah.
Why did you do that?
Because I thought it was,
but I was going to go.
He mind fucked.
You thought I was going to go high.
There's a lot of these kinds of things.
It's verbal.
Nonverbal.
Which magical psychologist.
A mixture of all kinds of different
things.
Twisted up a spoon.
It's on.
That shouldn't.
Yeah,
I did that.
I definitely want you to come.
We go into the magic castle tonight,
by the way.
Are you?
Yeah.
You're welcome to come.
If it to the comedy store.
You're walking.
Yeah,
I'm working.
What time you work in there rather come
and see you so I'm not working.
You're not going to go ahead and see
some friends.
My scrubs is actually a good friend of
mine,
Steve Valentine,
I don't know if you know Steve is
inactive.
No,
I don't really graves and crossing
Jordan and stuff like that and he's got
an interesting story about his life and
it's not that a psychological thing as
well,
which I'm always fascinated with where
he was performing magic for years,
constantly performing magic and um,
he wouldn't be enacted and the magic was
kind of a side thing for him,
but it started getting away.
He'd go on interviews and stuff and they
say,
you know,
aren't you that guy that does kit shows,
I want you to do a party for me and so
forth.
And he could never get the part.
So he started denying that he was a,
a magician.
I just totally left magic completely.
People say,
yeah,
I got your business card.
No,
that's not me.
That wasn't me.
That's when he started to be able to act
and he started getting the acting jobs
and everything.
It wasn't till years later that he could
go back and be a performer.
Wow.
And it's a really interesting story,
but he does it with magic and teaching
and things and yeah.
Do you ever work with comedy and Magic
Club in Hermosa?
No.
I never have.
Yeah,
it's interesting because he mixes comedy
and magic together.
Like you'll have like a magician on the
show with comedian.
This was a few of those back in the days
that I worked where it was comedy Magic
Club type thing.
So yeah,
it's a good nights.
Did you ever teach this stuff?
I teach to other magicians.
I have,
I have videos of stuff.
I have books.
Uh,
so I definitely do teach,
but I don't teach one on one.
I never teach it.
I just don't have time to teach one on
one.
I'm always so busy working and trying to
teach like this stuff.
Like how do you do these things?
The metal bending have dvds out on that.
The teach musicians how to do that.
Yeah.
And I promise you they are not trick
foreclose those now.
Nails not trick forks.
They are.
Yeah.
Well,
just the fact that you could spin a
regular fork,
right this.
Well fuck.
Are you doing that man?
There was a way.
It sort of became the holy grail for me
when I can tell you how that came about
for me.
There was muscle walkie Kyoto I told you
that he could actually put it under a
chair and he would put it in something
and twists that I was doing an article
for the national enquirer.
I don't even think I could do that with
just my hands.
What's confused?
And a guy shows up.
You.
Yeah,
there was a way.
And the guy shows up,
a photographer shows up for me and he
said,
I want you to bend some silverware so
you know,
I,
I go,
oh,
you know,
and I,
I go to him,
you know,
and I go,
okay,
all right,
I'm going to bend something.
So I take one and I go like this and
next thing you know,
it's bending up like that.
And then I do another band for him.
He says,
this is going to take a while,
isn't it?
I go,
yeah.
He says,
just bend them up with your hand.
It's like,
well that's cheating,
which exactly what I was doing,
you know,
so I would say that said to cheating.
So he says,
now go ahead.
So I just start bending them up like
crazy crazy.
And next thing you know,
I had a twist and I remember exactly how
I got that twist.
So I called Randy up on the phone
because it was sort of the holy grail
thing,
looking for a way to actually do it.
And I went in there and have one of
those telephones.
I had the long cord,
you know,
all the way to the bathroom.
And I called Randy and I'm whispering
now and say,
Hey,
I just spent a fortune,
you know,
with my hands and I'll put a twist in
it.
And he goes,
yeah,
so what?
I go,
no,
no.
And I explained exactly how to do it.
Now all the mentalist used that
technique.
Yeah.
So this was a regular fork?
Yes.
And you twisted that right in front of
my face with one hand.
Hm.
Oh,
how the fuck he did it.
He not supposed to know he was supposed
to enjoy the mystery,
Joe.
Right.
Well,
I'm trying.
I know that you can be fooled.
It's very confusing that I could be
fooled so easily because this is a real
fork.
I know that there's a certain forks that
they make out a shitty metal.
It's like a nice heat it up and it
becomes like Super Bendy.
Yeah.
That's something that's.
I don't want to get too much into
methods and so forth,
but that's definitely not something I
use or would use.
Yeah,
and that looks just a little weird it
jerking off,
but I'm trying to get a dental monic
ejaculation that may or may not do it.
The thing about was weird is that how
easy that fork bent when I bend it when
you had it,
it was very strange.
The one that bent really easy when I
bend it and he said,
Oh,
you're doing it on your own.
It was so easy to bend,
right?
Like why would it.
Why was it so easy to bend now?
I'm can't tell you why at that moment.
Hmm.
That if you look now,
that's that fork right there and take a
look at it and see if it's easy to bend.
Now you'll see that it's not a heat in
this.
Fuck her up.
I'm going to make it easy to,
but it's because at that moment that's
the one that I was going to break.
I wanted to break that one.
It's very confused and it's a job.
Well,
it's amazing really,
because it.
You'll let people actually touch the
things and someone like me who knows
that you're doing a trick because you
told me that you're doing a trick and
yet I still can't figure out how the
fuck can you see me work.
You'll see I throw everything across the
stage and a lot of stuff.
I just leave for people afterwards
because I want them to interact with
those things.
I want them to take them home with.
No,
I can imagine.
Especially the forks.
Yeah.
After awhile,
you know,
that's just.
He just sat.
I mean,
you just sit and look at this fork
afterwards.
You're like,
okay,
I don't think I could do that.
Yeah.
I mean if I just gave you a regular
fork,
Jane,
when you think you can do that,
spin that.
No,
I don't think I could twist that thing
like that.
Remember we were talking about the TV
show.
We were talking about the TV show
earlier is I have a pitch.
It's out right now for a series which it
looks like it may be going somewhere so
I don't wanna say too much about it,
but it's bringing back the million
dollar challenge and it's going out to
James James,
Randy million dollar challenge and it's
to go out looking for psychics,
testing them under proper controls.
If they're trying to trick us,
maybe I'll expose their methods.
I will demonstrate my abilities
supposedly to do the exact same thing
under certain conditions as and it's
sort of what makes me the expert to go
out and try to find these things and see
what's really going on and it's sort of
a brain games meets,
meets the bunking meet psychic
phenomena,
but not every single one is going to be
debunking either.
It's only going to be really debunking
when somebody is purposefully going out
and trying to bullshit somebody in
trying to fool people will take
advantage of people.
It's very baffling stuff,
but the stuff about talking to be bold
and ask them questions and reading their
cues.
That kind of makes sense,
but this doesn't make sense at all.
Fork stuff just does not make sense.
It's really weird because the PK stuff
is something as a mentalist,
as a performer,
you tend to pick your powers,
right?
You tend to.
Well you wouldn't because you're not as
performance ourselves.
When we performed this type of stuff,
we go,
okay,
does that fit sort of in the repertoire
of my abilities?
Do I have x Ray Vision?
You know,
I drive cars blindfolded,
you know dough in there,
they put tape over,
they see me do something along those
lines on your show and it's this thing
of like you pick your abilities and this
doesn't seem to fit with anything except
that your yellow did do this and also
said that he could duplicate pictures
and read minds once in a while as well.
I didn't do too much of the mind
reading,
but did a little bit of it.
Somebody would draw a picture,
then he would draw a picture and they
would match.
So which is a standard mentalism magic
trick anyway,
but his method is will a little bit more
bold.
A little bit more direct.
Hm.
Yeah.
I'm still baffled.
Stopped being baffled.
How could I not be bent some forks?
Maybe.
Maybe someday I'll teach you how to do
all this and I'll tell everybody know
that I want that.
I want to tell you,
don't tell them that again.
Tell you you can't tell me.
I'll fucking tell everybody
then nobody's going to be impressed when
you do it.
Well,
I don't care.
I just want everybody to know.
Is there anything else that you could do
that's fucked up?
Uh,
I didn't really bring a whole lot
because I've kind of just wanted to talk
more than anything else.
I mean,
what you've done as well.
It's very,
very impressive.
Maybe I can do one thing for you.
Okay.
Alright.
So see these.
You know what they are,
right?
No.
The zener cards.
Basically seeing the shapes,
basically five shapes that were,
um,
that were used at Stanford Research
Institute.
I Duke University,
actually not Stanford.
Duke University either created by
causing her a simple shapes.
There's a square,
there's a star wavy lines plus in a
circle.
All right.
These are the standard shapes right
there.
I'm going to try to get you to choose a
specific one.
Now,
psychologically,
if I asked you to choose one,
which would you say like,
I mean,
would you even say psychological?
The wavy lines that will be
psychological because it's right in the
middle.
And that would be the one.
All right,
so I'm going to go with um,
yeah,
I'm going to go with a star.
I think star,
there's a circle.
There's a square.
Uh,
the plus and the wavy lines are.
I'm going to mix them up so you don't
know which is which.
I'm going to have to look at them in
just a second myself to make sure I know
exactly where that is.
All right.
We can do this as the gambling thing or
not,
but I don't like to do that.
She'd probably rip people off strong.
I to put that in the right place.
Okay,
good.
So this is what we're going to do.
I'm going to take cards and I'm going to
ask you,
do you think the star is that card you?
All you have to do is not choose a star.
You're gonna.
Choose a star.
You won't know why you choose a star,
but you will choose the star.
All right?
You,
you won't have a.
He just will.
And it's gonna be something I do
something I say or something that it's
going to be something that I'm going to
try to make me pick the story.
This may or may not work,
right?
But snaky.
Pastor,
do you think this is?
Do you think I'm going to say yes,
that's the star you say?
Yes,
that's a star uses.
Okay.
So you're supposed to say no,
that's not the star at some point
because your idea is not to pick the
star.
I want you to not pick this up to
anyone.
So if you think that's the star right,
I will.
Okay.
So you're just gonna say,
do you understand?
Yes.
All right,
so here we go.
I know you're watching me close.
All right,
so let's do it again.
Hold already.
Flipped him around.
He makes them up one more time.
There's this sneaky hand movements are
so confusing.
Watch.
Okay.
No sleep.
Tamar,
which makes me sad.
These spent so much time learning how to
move your hands like this.
So I'm going to keep it simple.
Really simple for you.
My opinion.
Yeah.
Well I've cut it already.
So because I want to do it again because
I want to make,
make it very,
very hard.
If your job is to not choose the star,
right?
Okay.
Not Choose a star.
Ready.
All right.
So,
um,
I guess I'll just ask you,
do you want this card?
No.
All right.
So you don't want that one.
Don't want that one.
Do you want that card?
Don't choose a star.
Yes,
I want that one.
You sure?
That's the one you want.
That's the one I want
the look.
Okay.
I want to look there.
Look,
I don't trust you.
Watch my hand.
Don't look.
Don't look and see what you didn't
choose.
You didn't choose a circle.
She was a plastic,
didn't choose the wavy lines or the
square.
He chose a star.
They look
out of a bitch.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but that's like sleight of hand,
right?
Huh?
Well,
what?
What the hell is that what you're
talking about?
Which sleight of hand.
I try.
I try it one more time.
Who knows?
Okay.
To put in there.
All right.
I hate doing this stuff like this
because especially with the amount of
people that are listening to this
podcast,
what happens?
Don't know about wrong.
If I'm wrong,
I looked like an idiot.
If you're raw performance.
Yeah.
Somehow or another.
I think you're not going to be wrong.
I could be.
So once again,
I'm going to try and make you choose a
star.
Okay.
Your job is to not use it.
I'm not gonna.
Do it again after this.
This is the last time.
Do you want that card?
Yes.
That's the one you want.
That's the one I want to keep in mind.
You did that the first time.
Yeah,
right.
Don't look,
don't look square.
Circle plus wavy lines.
Stick.
Look.
Dammit.
Start.
Now.
Do you realize that I'm impulsive and
then I have no patience for the star
immediately.
He did it the first time.
So you thought that by doing it again,
that I would not think that you would do
it a second time.
Is that what you did?
Does that sort of kind of.
Not what I did
not going to tell us so that he's
getting frustrated,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I'm very impressed.
Well listen man,
this was a lot of fun.
It was fun.
I enjoyed it.
Thanks again for doing the TV show.
That was a lot of fun too.
And anytime.
And thanks for being so well you've done
it.
You've cleverly navigated the waters
being so honest about it being tricks
without revealing the tricks and then
even doing them in front of me,
which is incredibly impressive.
This fourth thing,
I don't know what to say.
Uh,
I don't know what to tell you.
Thank you.
This was fun.
I enjoyed it.
I really appreciate it for everything.
But everything you do and your website
is [inaudible] dot com.
[inaudible] DOT com,
b a c h e dot k.
and people can find out all your tour
dates,
the dates,
everything,
and you got to see this in real life
folks.
It's going to fuck you up.
Thank you sir.
Appreciate it,
man.